good evening everybody
and welcome to this virtual meeting of
the council
may i first remind all of you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking that your
cameras
are located in the correct position and
that you switch off your cameras
when not speaking so if i could ask you
all to switch off your cameras now
please
could you all switch off your cameras
please
that you do not interrupt other speakers
please use the raised hands facility
if you'd like to speak but please
refrain from using the other emojis in
the meeting
members are reminded not to use the
messaging
chat function during the meeting unless
unless it is to report a pecuniary or
non-pecuniary
interest or to notify the chair that you
wish to make a proposal
that if you're attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you'll be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair
please await your turn
if members lose connection to the
meeting please contact
the member support officer mandy smith
as soon as possible as this is a virtual
meeting
you will not need to stand to address
the chair
but please can you ensure that you
address your questions
and comments through the chair
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting
will be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented
to being filmed by entering this meeting
you are also consenting to being filmed
by the council
and to the possible use of those images
in sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and press
are not lawfully excluded
so we'll now move to the meeting
we'll move to the gender and i'm minded
to move the motion on notice
to before item eight on the agenda
therefore the order will now be items
one to seven
and then item 12 before returning again
to item 8 on the agenda
so we'll open the meeting now with item
1
apologies for absence thank you chair
we have no apologies for absence thank
you
item two declaration of interest by
councillors
in accordance with delegated authority
the monitoring officer
has granted dispensations to all members
in respect of the 21 22 budget papers
do we have any other declarations
yes madam chairman it's councillor john
osborne
thank you councillor osborne i don't
have your declaration please yeah i'd
like to declare a non-pecuniary interest
in what is i believe still item eight on
the agenda it's the general fund budget
as i'm a trustee on the citizen's advice
thank you very much
thank you is that counselor arthy
yes thank you chairman um just for
clarity can we just confirm that those
of us that are on
paris councils who obviously have a
precept through the budget
that we have a dispensation as well i'll
ask our monitoring officer
thank you chairman um just to confirm
for members you do not need to declare
membership of a parish council
um as either a local number country or a
pecuniary interest
for the purposes of the budget setting
um it's not an interest that you need to
declare because it's a
an appointment um it's not it's not kind
of affecting you personally so that's
absolutely fine
counselor maybe
uh thank you thank you chair thank you
chairman i thought for a moment my hand
was not
um working um on on the screen
i would like to declare a non-pecuniary
interest in
quite a few items on the agenda because
i am a
director of sudbury and district
citizens advice
fine thank you that's noted
are there any other declarations
thank you in that case if there are no
other declarations we'll now move on to
item
three bc 2023
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 19th january
2021 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
fine may i have a proposal please
i'll praise it sean is that
counselor of spawn yeah dawson oh
councillor prepared to propose that
madam chairman
fine so if cather dawson
seconds and councillor adrian osborne
proposes thank you
great thank you very much i will now ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair if councillors if you
can open the vote in the modern.gov app
by clicking the plus sign
in the top right hand of the agenda
screen and then selecting
attendance and voting the voting tab
will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote and councillor lindsay we can
we will take your vote manually thank
you
thank you
yeah councillor mel vasey and councillor
plum
are you okay to vote or is there or are
you experiencing problems
it's just counsellor melvaisy now
and councillor lindsay can i take your
vote please
yes four thank you sorry
thank you so that was 30 votes for and
two abstentions
so the vote is carried thank you so the
minutes um have been confirmed
and will be signed at the next
practicable opportunity
item four leaders announcements
i would like to invite councillor ward
to present his update
please can you email any questions and
points of clarification
you may have for him after the meeting
as i'm conscious that we have a very
long agenda this evening
council award thank you chair yes so we
have got a long agenda so i'll try and
um be brief on on this but
i do just want to highlight four things
if i may
firstly 19 we're now well into a
sustained period of significant weekly
decreases in infections
the latest data from the suffolk corona
watch site shows that here in baby the
infection rate is now down to 52.2 per
100 000 which is so much better than a
few weeks ago
in total we've had 3708 confirmed cases
and sadly 209 deaths since the pandemic
began began
although this latest number is the
latest data from the ons and is only up
to the 5th of february
the progress that has been made in
recent weeks with the delivery of the
vaccines
despite this progress has catapulted
suffolk up the league tables in terms of
delivery of the first doses to the first
four
cohorts and we are now one of the best
performing parts of the country
approximately sixty thousand
vaccinations have now been delivered and
capacity is currently standing at twenty
thousand four hundred per week
in suffolk and north east essex and
seventeen thousand two hundred
per week in west suffolk the latest news
about the effectiveness of the two
vaccines is also really encouraging
the work clearly isn't done however and
last week i met with ed garrett from our
ccgs to ensure that we are working as
closely as possible with the nhs to
support the delivery of the vaccine
together we will be targeting our
resources and getting to the minority
that qualify but have not yet received
their jab
it is also really good to see a huge
increase in testing capability with the
new community testing program
rapid asymptomatic testing sites are
being rolled out across the county
there's now one in cornard neyland
opened yesterday
holbrook will open on thursday and
hadley on friday
i'm also really pleased that we have
been able to extend our council tax
hardship scheme
to provide further help to the most
vulnerable in our district who have been
most impacted by covet
we now know the government's plans for
leading us out of this lockdown
there are lots of reasons to be hopeful
but in the meantime i would like to
reiterate our wider suffolk messages
that suffolk needs you to follow the
guidance
hands-face space to get tested regularly
if you're unable to work from home and
to get your cover jab when it's your
turn
ins in return suffolk supports you
through home but not alone and our
community
involvement the distribution of business
grants self-isolation payments
and and practical support for those most
in need
moving on now to bins i mentioned the
snow earlier and although it is now
melted away
i wanted to pay tribute to our bing cruz
who were back out within 48 hours
including working on the past two
saturdays making collections and
clearing the backlog as best they could
despite the weather
they have now managed to catch up
despite additional staff absences due to
several having to go into isolation
as it was half term last week i also
want to highlight the fantastic
initiative that we have in place
building on what we did during the
christmas holidays to tackle holiday
hunger
this scheme involves food ingredients
for five meals for a family of four
distributed to families during half term
the initiative delivered on behalf of
the council by admin croft leisure's
explore outdoor team ensures that no
child goes hungry when free school meals
are passed
uh paused during the school holidays
families in need are identified by local
schools
and the food parcels also include ideas
on how to make food stretched further in
future
making a real difference to the lives of
low-income families in our district
finally many of you will have heard that
the sale of chilton woods to taylor
wimpy has been completed
we can now look forward to this new
community grow over the coming years and
babel will ensure that we're involved in
delivering sustainable transport
infrastructure
needed to integrate it into the greater
sudbury area
thank you chair thank you council award
we'll now move on to item five to
receive notification of petitions
in accordance with council procedure
rules
thank you chair please be advised we
have received the following validated
petitions
364 valid signatures urging the council
to reconsider and continue to fund
the customer access point and number two
34 valid signatures urging the council
to reconsider and continue to fund
the customer access point in its current
location for at least two years
both petitions have been dealt with
through the petitions process
thank you chair thank you item six
questions by the public in accordance
in accordance with council procedure
rules none received chair
thank you item seven questions by
councillors
in accordance with council procedure
rules none receive chair
as mentioned earlier we're now going to
move on to
item 12 which is the motion
on notice
just to con
to consider the motion received from
counselor crosswell
thank you so we have a long agenda this
evening i'll be limiting the debate on
this motion to
30 minutes councillor kurzweil would you
like to move the motion
thank you chair i'll read my motion
dear members counselor allison owen and
myself bring this motion that the
council
does not have faith in the leadership of
john ward and ask
that he resigns with immediate effect
alice and myself were elected in may
2019
as a couple of political novices as we
met councillor award
spoke over a coffee were more than happy
for him to show he was the right person
to lead the council forward i'm now
going to try to explain
why we feel this decision needs making
council award
is the leader of the cabinet has played
a leading role in the
decision at sudbury in the surrounding
parishes without proper
consultation of the people who elected
us all as
as councillors he's part of the decision
decision-making
has led to protest marches petition hit
debate in the papers
and in the town council meetings the
first
decision we felt councillor will got
wrong after the
our election was to try and change the
name from baber to south suffolk
this went to full council and it was
rejected by many
fellow tories it was the first time i'd
seen council award try and push things
through
without doing his due diligence we all
know
we were told it would cost nothing but
we all know that wasn't the truth
there was logos on all the council
vehicles plus all the paperwork and
everything else
that goes with it and the list goes on
the next thing was council awards baby
the hotel at bellevue park
and he was definitely not listen to
sudbury residents or anyone whose views
were different
regards the hotel in the park we were
repeatedly told
that the residents of sudbury want at
the hotel in the area
and we even had officers come down from
baby to the mayor's parlor in sudbury
telling us the same showing us slides
a few months later the hotel fell
through and the paper
issued a pie chart it showed that 75
of the town did not want the hotel in
that position
it was oversight we will now go on to
the access
and advice center moving to the library
the town council were not informed
where it was going although i knew a
month before it was announced
the staff of 2.8 people being told they
may be made redundant just before
christmas
lovely the town clock repeatedly asking
for information and getting nothing
the way the leader and to a certain
degree cabinet mint has dealt with this
was appalling
the town council felt like we were being
lied to
as the baby was saying the town council
were asking for more money
which was not the truth babe were
putting less money in
year after year from year two
after spending sixty thousand pounds to
set up at the town hall and running a
monday to friday service for the old
vulnerable we have been told that the
service is gonna
from the first of eight was going to run
on a monday and a thursday two days a
week
with the odd day put in if required to
save thirty thousand pounds
but cut the service by sixty percent at
a time when we have the most
difficult periods since world war two
and
are heading for mass unemployment and
the people with the least skills
who need help a face-to-face meeting
with a person they can relate to
what get us an ipad or a laptop to a
person who has no
idea how to use them or in or no
internet at home to connect to
councillor parker said at the meeting
reference
his own business was going towards
online sales
i agree entirely but this is not a car
insurance
a holiday house insurance this is
insulting this is people's lives
say universal credits their council tax
and things that are very very important
to them this will cause stress
and more mental health problems now
the ladies are going to do the same
amount of hours i've been told as they
were going
they were doing at the town hall but
three days might not be in suffering
three days maybe at stone market how
does that fit into the carbon footprint
uh councillor mill vasey
and council award you go on about going
green
and there we are we're going to send
people perhaps to stone market three
days a week
and if they live in different areas
they've got to take their own cars
now we'll go on to the car parking
car parking free car parking for three
hours in sudbury
and headley this had nothing to do with
going green but a short-term financial
fix
thomas morelli put in a petition which
wasn't accepted because it was on
postcodes but
engaged the feeling of the town 1600
plus signatures in a very short space of
time
and some people didn't want to give full
addresses because they didn't really
want
to give full addresses to people they
didn't know
so counselor well you have 30 seconds
okay suffers got an 8 vacancy rate the
national average is 14.
is this because we have free parking 84
the car parks is paid by business rates
so i've brought up four areas which
major wards is
massively involved but he's not
listening to people not listen to
residents i didn't like being called a
coward in the paper which i'm not
a lot of councillors get four years like
i get
at the council council sorry thank you
very much
thank you can i have a seconder please
cancer own you're muted
sorry i got one thing right tonight
thank you i'd like to second that
um can i leave it to the end for my bit
yes you can that's fine thank you thank
you
right we'll now move to debate councils
will only be allowed
to speak once and for three minutes and
this will be timed
so would you would anyone like to start
the debate counselor
uh lindsay you madam chair um
i'm uh going to vote for this motion
um uh and i
but i don't um i do so slightly
reluctantly because i
i don't like making things personal and
um
i have some respect for for john ward
a council award um but
i do think um that the problem he has
is the system he's agreed to
set up the cabinet system
um which isn't working to
include all councillors views and
particularly not
um councillors from all parties um he
made a decision at the start of this
term to exclude the green party
from the cabinet and to exclude labour
from the cabinet
um there were 23 percent of people
in baber of voters voted green
and i just think it's completely unfair
and undemocratic
to decide to exclude that voice from the
decision-making body of the council
if we've got to have a cabinet system it
should at least
include a proper political balance in
that cabinet
and i believe the cabinet even now
doesn't reflect political balance across
the council
and there's only one person you can
blame for that and that's council award
um so i should be supporting this
motion and i look in future
to move to a committee system which is
what baby used to run
which allowed all councillors who are
all elected after all
by equal amounts of the electorate to
have their say thank you
thank you councillor lindsay councillor
beer
thank you madam chairman i'll keep my
remarks more to the parking side
well members this is a bit rich this
motion coming from councillors creswell
and owen read the question that this
council has no
faith in the present leadership whatever
that may mean
may i remind you that two weeks ago at
the cabinet meeting
there was an opportunity for members to
challenge
and put questions about these issues in
particular
parkhan in sudbury and hadley madame
chairman
you and your two headley colleagues
kenzler dawson
and kenzler fraser supported each other
and all three of you
argued your concerns against the parking
charges in hadley
i was very impressed meanwhile i alone
argued against the parking in sudbury
and was not supported
by any sub remember
councillors creswell and owen did not
even bother to attend the meeting or to
take part
to join in or even give me some support
in trying to make a case
i battled on alone where were you
counselor creswell and owen i asked you
where were you
you did not speak up
up against the um and argued against the
charge in for sudbury you did not
support my case
you remain silent very silent
but now you're jumping on the bandwagon
for political gains
i believe that the people of sudbury and
great corner were let down badly by you
and your colleagues and now the motion
of
no faith against the leader should be
rejected
and that i now say and
i would suggest that we have no faith in
you
as sudbury councillors creswell and owen
thank you thank you councillor beer
councillor ayers
thank you chair i actually do support
this motion
because um i am elected as a councillor
and i'm here to contribute to good
covenants
and to encourage community participation
and citizen involvement in decision
making
which is under our constitution part 1
2.3 um dotty two
three and four um i'm here to
effectively
represent the interests of my ward and
of individual constituents which is what
i've been trying to do
and to respond to their inquiries and
their representations fairly
and impartially i have had so many
people
because my name and address is still
outside the town hall some people have
taken theirs
off and i have so many people
say to me what on earth is john moore
doing
it's very sad and i have been inundated
with
letters replying to peter beer i was
there at that meeting but having sent
emails
and whatever i've been totally ignored
the other thing is looking through the
little book that we were given when we
were elected
profile and it says the main purpose of
the role of the leader
is to promote the work of the council
and to champion
public service needs on behalf of local
residents
businesses and visitors he has not done
this
i had an email last night saying the
library was only visited by an officer
last friday i rest my case thank you
thank you councillor as councillor john
osborne
thank you madam chairman um if i was
given longer i i'd speak
i would challenge um some of the
comments that councillor creswell has
made
however given the time i have got i will
say that council award is a man with
integrity
commitment and knowledge for those
councillors who
were councillors before the 2019
elections
you will remember that council award
went out
to our town and parishes on a saturday
morning to reach out and engage
this approach has never ever been done
before and unfortunately kovic prevented
him from doing the same
after the 2019 elections he works
many many hours for the good of baber
and its people
you may not always agree with him but
that does not make him a bad leader
i have every faith in council award and
i will not
be supporting this motion thank you
madam chairman
thank you councillor osborne uh
councillor mcfrazer
yes thank you madam chairman uh i won't
be supporting this
um councillor fraser um we've got a
problem with your headphone
if i think you need to bring your
microphone bit that's it thank you
yeah i've got two out of three right sal
thank you for that madden chairman
um yeah sorry um my apologies to
everyone
start again sure certainly thank you
thank you
um uh madam chairman i won't be
supporting this
motion uh neither uh
at the last baber meeting uh i spoke
uh predominantly about hadley and
councillor creswell
picked me up and commented on that
particular issue with parking
saying we were all in this together and
as councillor beers quite rightly
pointed out
at the cabinet meeting on the 4th of
february
uh i and the other hadley members and
peter
and councillor beer all spoke at that
cabinet meeting
with regards to all these issues and as
councillor beer quite rightly pointed
out
the other sudbury members were absent i
don't understand this motion a motion
asking for a resignation
surely the strength of a motion would be
our vote of no confidence
with a prospective replacement leader in
place
and there's no evidence of that and if
we're going to talk about chronological
events when we were elected in 2019
i recall there been an issue of we the
conservative group
not having an overall majority and
council award
making that determined leadership move
to actually involve
other parties and independents to
actually form
a cabinet and an administration to move
this council forward i reiterate i won't
be supporting it for those reasons
thank you thank you councillor fraser
councilman of easy
thank you madam chairman this is more a
point of information
the cabinet system is working and
working very well
but members need to take on board that
they can attend
cabinet briefings they can attend and
put questions
to cabinet it's very sad that in my time
as a district councillor no member has
attended
to do this the opposite the opposite
side if we call them that
um mid suffolk they are well the members
are well represented
and do challenge the thinking so
members you have to take the
responsibility that
you can attend you can question us you
can challenge our thinking
but you have singularly failed to so
do because not one has turned up
management by committee is universally
recognized
as the most inefficient inefficient and
ineffective
method of management i will be
not supporting this um motion thank you
thank you councilman fizzy councillor
mabry
thank you very much chairman um
i would like to point out to councillor
may malvizi that i have
attended a cabinet meeting um and i have
spoken
um i will be supporting this motion
and i'm afraid uh councillor air sort of
support
um took my thunder from the constitution
under article two um
if members would like to look at it
which is the roles and functions of all
councillors
there are several items there that i
believe council award
is not doing at the moment
i am not going to break any
confidentiality
but i can certainly quote from
one of my residents who actually said to
me when
they had a problem with a refuse
collection
that they asked council award about it
and his reply was well my
my dustbins are emptied i can't see why
you've got a problem
now i don't call that very good
leadership
i am actually very pleased to say that i
sorted
this residence issue out
quite fairly and within
24 hours and i'm just wondering why
council award could not have done that
too considering he's probably
in a better place to actually um speak
to offices
there are quite a few instances
where residents have spoken to me at
length
about council awards leadership
some i think um i would never ever
repeat
um i'm too much of a gentle woman
but i must say it has all been negative
i have not had one person who actually
thinks that
council award is doing a good job in
leadership at the moment
um so i will definitely be supporting
this motion thank you
thank you councillor mayberry council
mccraw
thank you madam chair uh i'm approaching
this from a slightly different angle
uh that of overview and not scrutiny
sometimes i feel like piggy in the
middle between council and uh
cabinet and i do attend cabinet actually
every time
councillor malvisi slightly missed the
fact that i too am a member
and not a member of cabinet uh and i'm a
councillor
it's been incredibly difficult year
possibly the worst that baber has
ever faced and i think i'd like to argue
for a sense of perspective here
we have before us tonight a balanced
budget
now during 2020 that possibility seemed
quite frequently remote we know we've
got balanced
uh budget pressures coming up in the
next three years
despite all of this and the horrible
year with the kovid 19 pandemic the
essential work has continued and that's
the job of the council
the council received a lot of praise
during that year for the work done by
members and officers
in handling the pandemic grant
distribution
and a variety of other things now the
three issues
being mentioned uh in the supporting
argument
by councillor creswell are have all been
addressed and they're all rather
disconnected issues they're not the
work of a single person they're the work
of a variety of different
decision-making processes again i've had
the opportunity to look at these
i think perhaps there's a disconnect i
think that's fairly clear
and i'd like to comment on why i think
there's a disconnect because
perhaps due to the pandemic the remote
meetings we've lost that personal
contact we used to have with each other
on a human level uh where we bump into
each other chat things over
and be able to have those sorts of
informal conversations that
make life work because that's how life
works
so i think we have lost a sense of
perspective these uh
issues have been conflated in a way that
i don't think anybody's enjoyed
um i've looked at the decision making
process involved and
and and i'm more than satisfied that
proper processes have been followed
and i've always worked hard to ensure
that they are according to the
constitution
the point about this motion is it
assigns blame
and i don't believe blame is appropriate
here for one individual
the leader or indeed any other
individual there are a variety of people
all working
separately but together towards a
constant aim and that's to make the
council work better
make it work make it work better not
everybody is going to agree with every
decision
but for those reasons i cannot support
this motion
and i would urge other members not to
support it for the same reason
thank you thank you councilman crawl
council davis
thank you um yeah i concur with um
so what some of my fellow counselors
have said
and and i'll go slightly different as
well
when we're on the cabinet which is
something i didn't vote for
um all those years ago but haven't
haven't said that i've been part of the
cabinet for two administrations now
and uh i have to say i think this
administration
is a far more cohesive and productive
cabinet we've had to make some very
tough decisions
and i say the world we because john is
the leader
and he's the one that gets the brick
back but we're in this together
and we've made the decisions for the
benefit and for the the best
of all of all residents in in baby
it's not a popularity contest yes people
are
maneuvering towards elections and yes
some people have got their own personal
acts to grind but basically where
we are here for the best of the uh the
residents and john ward
i have to say and i would be the first
there's an independent
to speak out if i didn't think he was
doing a good job a is a councillor
b is a cabinet member because don't
forget he's got his own portfolio which
he's
i think produced absolutely miracles
with his team
and getting this budget through as well
getting to this budget together
but also as a leader and i know about
leadership i've
been part of many good teams and i've
seen good leaders and i've seen bad
leaders
and i'll say unequivocally john ward is
a good leader
he's an excellent leader of baber
district council
and quite frankly i don't think there's
anyone else there that is
willing or able to do the job at the
moment so i will most definitely
not be voting for this motion thank you
thank you councillor davis councillor
huron
yes thank you madam chairman um i won't
be supporting this because i think quite
honestly
it rather smacks of um political
opportunities
opportunism um so yeah
there we go that's better um but i do
think in some ways we do have a bit of a
problem we we seem to present things
very badly
which i know is down to the comms team
and sometimes we just
don't seem to think ahead which does
concern me
just recently in the press labor
councillors
have been quite slanted and there's a
reason for that
i know that aleister spoke of disconnect
and yes maybe that is
part of it i think we've lost a bit of
teamwork
and in a long email exchange with john
he was a neighboring councillor of mine
and i do have respect for and
i think um he does a pretty good job but
in an email exchange he said the problem
well i was trying to get him to listen
to my point of view
he said the problem was that people
didn't listen
now for somebody to say that others
aren't listening um
may mean that he's not listening himself
so i think maybe
there is a problem there in a private
conversation maybe i can give john a few
um
words of advice i think he's basically a
good leader
but he does suffer a bit from what i
call ipswich teronitis
um recent managers the more wrong they
go the more they try and defend the
impossible
and i think john just does need to have
a little bit of advice
and um just present himself a little bit
better and
the thoughts of the council as well i
may abstain or if
other people say good things about john
i may just about
support him but it's a bit on a knife
edge thank you chairman
thank you councillor haran councillor
hardaker
hello i am i want to say that i will be
supporting this motion
um i've i'm a new counselor from the
2019 intake and
it has been a constant stream of car
crash
um newspaper headlines retractions
walk-backs u-turns
since then and most of the time they
have um
unfortunately john ward's name on them
um
i'd like to correct some of our opinions
on some of the things that have been
said recently
in this debate um it has been mentioned
um that the pandemic has played a part
in this but that's not true the
big name change was pre-pandemic most of
the hotel development was pre-pandemic
um john's also been praised during this
debate for
his working together to bring the
council together um
for his cabinet system to make it
representative but the green party got
nearly one quarter of the vote and one
eight for the councillors and have
no seats on cabinet so it's clearly
an attempt to consolidate power in a
party which does not have a majority
and that's how most of the deals and
things were put together
from my point of view as for cabinet
and other councillors being invited
cabinets i see two solutions to this
one is that maybe all counselors just go
to every council meeting and just they
can just become 32 member accounts
cabinet meetings if that's the case if
we if that's the only way we can be
involved in decision making
secondarily um if these decisions
are going through a cabinet and
cabinet's approving them and these
u-turns are happening
then maybe the entire cabinet isn't
suitable we need to look again like john
um that robert said at the cabinet or if
if not the
model itself for the council of the
capitalist makeup
thank you thank you councillor hardika
was there anyone else who wished to
speak
councillor ward
yeah i suppose i want to say a few words
if that's all right um uh
but thanks councillor haron comparing me
to it's rich managers hopefully not the
recent ones i'd
very successful but um that's um another
matter
just a couple of things um councillor
mabry's uh
not so sure that um any of that is uh
particularly accurate so
normally uh when people contact me about
refuse collection i get onto it very
quickly and uh lots of emails between me
and the relevant corporate manager
confirming this so
um i i just questioned the nature of
councilman avery's stories there
um but um the accusations that we don't
consult are engaged
are simply not borne out by the facts on
two of the three issues in sudbury
bellevue and parking
we have consulted and listened to
opinion and we have compromised
a fact that is not accepted by those
behind this motion
council creswell says that the bellevue
hotel is my baby but proposals for this
go back
long before i was elected to this
council in 2015.
over the years have been uh there has
been a consultation on various plans as
they've come forward including since i
became leader two public exhibitions a
public meeting
as well as on parking we listened to the
correspondence we received
we listened to last month's petition
debate and we listened to the overview
and scrutiny committee
the result was that we amended the paper
to reach a compromise and many accept
that this compromise is reasonable
there you go that word compromise that's
the essence of politics
but having said all this i and the
cabinet do recognize that there needs to
be a way of involving council more in
the more contentious executive decisions
and so we will need to explore options
for this
now to address my leadership style as
there's clearly an intent to personalize
the things that cabinet and the council
do
i know that there are lurid claims about
my role in decision making being made
online by a sizable group have used this
as a justification for extreme personal
abuse
which has been going on for nearly two
years now i've had a death threat dealt
with by the police
threats of violence and only today i was
advised that there is a photo of me with
a target on my head on facebook
how sick can people get this is
disgusting behavior and it is deplorable
that elected members of this council
would seek to offer its support
i'm not an elected executive mayor and i
do not have the authority of such an
office
we operate a cabinet governance model
here and executive decisions are made by
the cabinet
and it is not a supine cabinet i made
sure that it is made up of strong
individuals from three groups on this
council
individuals who are not shy 30 seconds
take one example council buzzfeed you
all know dave and the notion that he
could be told what to do by anyone is
fanciful
no this motion is not about consultation
or engagement or listening
which means every effort to do or indeed
me it seems to be nothing more than uh
sudbury town council through its proxies
here trying to tell this council what to
do
we're the district council and we must
make decisions for the benefit of all of
our residents thank you chair
thank you council award i'll go to
councillor artsy
and then councillor owen and then that
will be all
councillor arty um yeah my first thought
is that i'm sure this is really
uncomfortable for council award
um i hope that wasn't the sole intention
of the motion um and i do
feel for him um i'm always happy to
listen to councillor cresswell
but i i don't agree with him here and
i'm
happy to offer john ward my wholehearted
support
to use the words from the motion in fact
i do have faith
in john lord's leadership 20 months ago
we
we had a huge task on our hands to put
together a workable administration
under the cabinet model with which we
currently have to work
that could be changed but currently we
have to work within within that
and that's the position we were in 20
months ago
john took on the role of leader and
appointed a mixed cabinet drawing on
councillors from across the political
groups
the last 20 months and others have said
this too i think councilman mccraw
the last 20 months have presented huge
challenges
and john has risen to those challenges
with real commitment
his matter of fact style might not suit
everyone
but we don't offer him a challenge we
should offer him
thanks so my thanks go to john for what
he's done over the last 20 months
and i have every confidence in him being
able to continue to the end of the term
thank you councillor rc
um and i'm sorry councillor busby
um we have reached the 30 minutes that
i've set aside for this time
so i'm afraid there won't be time for
you to speak
so i'll move now to councillor owen who
reserved her right to speak earlier
so councillor owen thank you chair um
can i just say this
is not political at all one little bit
right council award has not been open
and transparent to the council
councillors on the back benches i feel
that he has let
sudbury hadley and the surrounding
villages down
if we do not have the information before
the events we do not have the ability
to represent the public sudbury has been
hit with
two major disruptions this year alone
the advice center which is reducing the
hours and that affects all villages
around us as well as sudbury car parking
the town mayors asked for
reconsiderations until the parking
reveal was done
that was rejected and who knows what
we'll bring for bellevue house and our
old pool site let us hope we'll listen
to on that
we were told that the cabinet was
democratic but with eight seats and no
greens
which they have four councillors where
is the democracy there
we are baby's biggest town and surely in
our own right we should be listened to
i urge the councillors who feel that
they need a change to vote with us
on this motion and this is not personal
okay thank you thank you councilloran
councillor croswell if you've got
anything you'd like to add
sorry no i i sorry i am
i agree with allison i i have personally
have got no problem with
council award um i just feel that some
of the things that have been done
haven't been right
and um that's why we decided with the
motion we could have sat there and done
nothing
but i have so many people come up to me
in the street
who are absolutely cheesed that's the
only way you can put it in like
cheesed off with the present situation
what is going on in our town
i'm afraid i'm the same as alison
suez and all the sudbury town
councillors who are well known in the
town
and even walking the dog there'll be
somebody come up with me
saying can't you do anything about it so
we've gone around it
the way we thought was best and uh
mr ward has got good points but
mr ward's biggest point would be to
listen
and listen to the people and as for
saying
they did a survey on the car parking
a day or week in february is not the way
you do a survey you do it over a
sustained period of time
summer months included to find out what
people's habits are because they're very
different
in the summer to the winter thank you
for listening
and um i hope people vote with us thank
you thank you chair
thank you councillor crosswell so we're
going to move to
the electronic vote now please remember
everyone when you do
vote if you're voting for
councillor ward to remain leader
you have to vote against
the motion so
um and i think um our corporate manager
governance is going to explain that as
well
so i'd like to now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors can you open
the vote in the modern.gov app by
clicking the plus sign in top right hand
of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting the
vote for this agenda item will show in
blue but you may need to tab down
to the bottom to find the blue line and
just for clarity
you will need to vote for in support of
the motion asking council awards to
resign
or against if you don't want to support
the motion thank you
councillors beer and hinton we're still
waiting for you to vote
um are you experiencing any technical
issues
uh oh yes it's gone all together now
hang on
i'll try again uh where are we let's go
into it
ah you know it's getting this bar to
move down it's not easy
all right let's see if i can
i can't get it to move down
cancer i'll take your vote manly if you
like
yes uh i'm i'm voting against the
emotion
against the motion thank you
why wouldn't that work
try that again
thank you um the boating is now complete
um we have
ten boats for the motion 20
against the motion and two abstentions
[Music]
thank you so that that motion is lost
we'll now move back to the agenda
item 8 bc 2024 general fund budget
for 2021 and 22 and four
year outlook i would like to invite
council award
to introduce paper bc 2024
and to move the recommendations in the
report
as this is a complex paper i'm minded to
allow council award
and councillor jameson who is tabling
the amendment
and their seconders longer than the
normal time allowed in these
circumstances
all other counsellors will have three
minutes
so thank you council ward um if you'd
like to present your paper
yes i would thanks chair at last we got
a nonsense out of the way we can get on
this
serious business what our residents
elected us to do not play childish games
but before i start i'd first like to
give my heartfelt thanks to the finance
team
every year they work extremely hard over
autumn and winter on the budget for not
just
one but two councils and they've had to
discuss and agree their contents with
two cabinets
but this year they have also had to deal
with the requirements of covert 19
preparing regular reports of the impact
on our finances to the mhclg
assessing how the government's support
has helped and also ensuring the
government's business grants are
available for us to distribute promptly
the section 151 officer has built an
excellent team
and we should all be very grateful for
that
so now to introduce the report i'm
pleased to introduce report bc 2024 for
the 2021 to 22 general fund budget
for your outlook this year we are an
entirely unforeseen
new and difficult situation the world
has a very different place from where it
was
when i presented last year's budget
indeed the fact that we are doing this
online rather than the council chamber
is a very visible reminder of this it is
no exaggeration to say that we have had
to prepare this budget under the most
challenging of circumstances
the impact of code 19 has hit us on top
of having to respond
to the continuing fall in government
funding for local authorities
the financial impact of covet this year
has been constantly evolving
and our initial very wiring assessment
has been ameliorated by
very generous government support
although the latest forecast
is that it will fall short of our
increased costs and loss of income
by 400 000 pounds and the government
hasn't only been generous to local
authorities
there have been substantial grants for
businesses and residents in need
there is a gain uncertainty this year
over the core funding that will be
available over the medium term
the three-year comprehensive spending
review has been delayed again and a
one-year review was published in
november
focusing on continuing the response to
covered
this does seem a sensible decision by
government given the current
circumstances
and the longer term review can wait
until we are in recovery
the financial support for covered
pressures will continue into the first
quarter of next year
as will the rural services delivery
grant additional support for businesses
in the current lockdown has also been
provided
the government has confirmed that the
fair funding review business rates
review and business rates reset
have been deferred yet again i'd like to
draw your attention to the announcement
with a four billion pound
leveling up fund for infrastructure to
support recovery
this supersedes the local pinch point
fund and so the
suffolk county council expression of
interest for sudbury will be rolled over
to the new fund
the financial settlement for 2021-22
does give us additional funding of 724
thousand pounds
which 199 000 pounds has been built into
the budget
and the rest either transferred to
earmark reserves or used to cover
business rates and council tax losses
there is a new local council tax support
grant of 115 000 pounds
a new lower tier services grant of 91
000 pounds to compensate for reduction
in the final year new homes bonus
payments
and ensure that core spending power
isn't reduced
four hundred and fourteen thousand
pounds of the fifth transcovered funding
and an extra eleven thousand pound rural
service delivery grant to increase this
to two hundred and
um thirty eight thousand pounds have
also been provided
we've also benefited by a hundred and
eleven thousand pounds of compensation
for under
indexing the business rates multiplier
which is included in the section 31
grant
this is all now been incorporated in the
funding for this budget
with the exception of the covet fund
until we have assessed any additional
financial impact in 2021 to 22.
76 000 pounds of 115 000 local council
tax
support grant has been included and will
be transferred to the collection fund
reserve
while the remaining thirty nine thousand
pounds will be distributed
to town and parish councils the parish
allocations are provided in appendix c
in addition to the to the financial
settlement the budget
requires 692 000 pounds or 83 percent of
the anticipated 2021 to 22 new homes
bonus receipts
there will only be one small new homes
burners payment next year and nothing
after that
as ever there is a complicated picture
regarding business rates
we are forecasting an additional 215 000
pounds in business rates funding
and budget also requires all of the
section section 31 business rates grant
of 1.5 million pounds
which is a net overall reduction of 91
000 pounds compared with the current
year's budget
once all the elements have been taken
into account
changes to the business rates levy and
pooling benefit will result in a further
net reduction of 59 000 pounds in
funding
the forecast business rates deficit of
658 000 pounds
for the current year can now be spread
over the next three years which is good
we will again and i know none of us
likes this be increasing council tax at
the maximum level allowed without
requiring a referendum
which is five pounds per year or two
point nine six percent for a band d
property the annual council tax for
abandoning property will now be 173
pounds 86
as a result of increasing numbers of
people claiming the local council tax
reduction scheme
and a lower a lower collection rate we
have based the budget on a 0.3
reduction in the tax base incidentally
this is not 2.2 percent as stated on
page 66 of your report which is an error
but this may increase if the numbers
claiming support increases
the net effect is that we are
forecasting a total council tax increase
of 39 000 pounds this year
but this is helped by the local council
tax support grant
the budget setting process has again
seen line-by-line budget challenges to
identify savings but the cabinet has
also had to make some difficult
decisions
in addition to the council tax increase
which to me is the most difficult
we have also approved a revision to our
parking tariffs we have increased the
garden waste collection fee
we have increased we have removed the
locality budgets and 317 swims for this
year
and we have um implemented a general
three percent increase for our fees and
charges
my new sudbury customer access point
will also provide considerable savings
although i must reiterate that its
primary purpose is to deliver a better
service on the plus side we are
continuing our support for the submarine
hcabs at the same level
we are able to finance the transfer to
hydro-treated vegetable oils for our
vehicle fleet
for the next offset by travel cost
reductions
we are forecasting ict cost savings 128
000 pounds
overall we are forecasting a surplus of
143 000 pounds
the unused portion of new homes bonus
receipts although we are currently
predicting surpluses for the uh the
current year but there's still a lot of
uncertainty regarding this and for the
2021-22 year
these shifts in the context of our
interim outlook which i will address in
a moment
we will use 335 000 pounds from earmark
reserves
for specific service expenditure but
this will be offset by some transfers in
most notable notably the 143 000 pound
budget surplus
from the new home's bonus receipts into
the new climate change and biodiversity
reserve
and the 414 000 pounds into the covered
reserve
this means that we are able to increase
our reserves in the forthcoming year
although the transformation fund will be
slightly lower it is essential that we
maintain reserves at this level so that
we can respond to our events without
impacting services at this point i would
like to mention that we are forecasting
a total 1.8 million pounds
net income from our cifco investments an
increase of 745 000 pounds on the
current year
totally
you know the storm and it's providing
much needed reliable income
on top of this we have four customers
nine thousand pounds from
uh
that the risk has been highlighted
regarding the relatively low level of
expenditure covered by our fees and
charges income
as the lowest percentage of comparable
authorities we will need to look more
closely at this in future
and ensure particularly that our
discretionary services take on more of
the financial burden
i thought you'd like to know that
compared to the last year as percentages
of our total income
council tax business rates and
government grants have all fallen
while fees and charges and our
investments have increased
this trend will indeed will have to
continue in the years to come
we also need to project a medium-term
four-year outlook which is both sensible
and sustainable
funding assumptions for the next four
years have shown in paragraphs eight
eleven to eight fourteen
was a four-year forecast included in
table six
the overall budget gap for the three
years from 2022 to 23
amounts of amounts to accumulative
deficit 1.7 million pounds further
significant income or savings or both
will be needed to address this
unfortunately we can no longer rely on
income from the bellevue hotel project
for the past five years we have used 81
of new homes bonus receipts
a total of 3.78 million pounds to
balance the budget
and this will no longer be available to
us
the capital program has set out an
appendix a and the plan spent for 2021
to 22
is 6.2 million pounds the financing for
this is shown in the second table in the
appendix
the major differences from this time
last year are that we will have
completed our cifco investments
by the end of the current financial year
and the bellevue capital investment is
no longer required now that the hotel
project will not take place
i just want to say a few words about
appendix e which sets out the flexible
use of capital receipts strategy
hitherto has been the rule that capital
receipts can only be used to support
capital expenditure
however recent guidance from the
government will now allow
some flexibility and enable capital
receipts in the period up to 31st march
2022
to be used to fund revenue spending if
that spending will generate ongoing
savings to our net service expenditure
this could be either through achieving
either reduced service delivery costs or
reduce demand for services
section two lists some examples of
transformation projects contained in the
strategy
that meet the criteria for appliance
flexibility
in order to respond to the challenges we
face both old and new we must continue
to be prudent to ensure that we have
stable finances for the future
and are in a position to continue to
deliver first-class services to our
residents
the continuing delay to the
comprehensive spending view does not
make our four-year outlook
sorry does make our four-year outlook
more uncertain and given that this was
already challenging for us
this is a worry but it is not just about
the finances
we must also continue to change the way
we do things
which is why we have an ongoing
transformation program
a key part of this is our customer
strategy that was adopted in the summer
of 2018.
we will ensure that we interact with our
residents in the ways
they want and this will increasingly use
technology to provide a better
experience at a lower cost
the latest example of this is the
recently launched chatbot service
which has already proven popular the
cabinet believes that this budget is a
sound one
and keeps us on the right path so that
we can continue to to deliver the
services
our residents need and want thank you
chair
thank you council award before we move
to
ask for a seconder and can i just say to
everyone can you
could all members refrain from using the
clack box
you will have an opportunity to ask
questions or debate
later on on this paper so please don't
use the chat box during um this meeting
thank you um right may i have a seconder
please counselor rc
are you um wishing to second this
yes thank you oh yes thank you chairman
yes i'll
happily second thank you thank you did
you want to speak now or do you want to
reserve your right to speak later
i'll reserve my right to later thank you
thank you
uh councillor jameson um i believe you
wish to propose an amendment
a draw members attention in case they're
not aware
the amendments that we're going to be
looking at
are on page 89 of your papers
um so counselor james so i wish you i
believe you wish to propose an amendment
from the green group
uh yes uh madam chair thank you very
much but before
i start could um you ask cancer normal
to retract his statement at the start of
that um
presentation which i'm sure he regrets
now um
if if members have concerns they want to
bring to
um to council it is not really
it's not deemed childish particularly if
it's been raised by residents
so i'm sure he didn't mean as it came
across but it was
not very good okay thank you you've made
you've made that statement thank you
right thanks again would you like to
move on with your
amendment please firstly the amendments
that we are presenting today aim to
cover key topics important to our
residents planning
planning and community needs
biodiversity and the planning committee
the sorry
uh yeah and the plan the climate crisis
many of our communities feel that they
are under siege by developers they have
no faith in the council or the planning
committee and no confidence in decisions
made
they then have little expectation that
we will hold developers to account if
the planning conditions are ignored
to restore faith it is essential that
planners and planning committees impose
conditions that work for communities
and that the conditions are enforced we
propose a second
an extra officer should join the hard
press team
our council should have the resource
time and training to ensure developers
contribute a fair share of their gains
to enhance the communities from which
they are profiting
to further improve the confidence of our
residents we recommend that all planning
committee members
undertake regular training our
amendments have allocated forty seven
thousand and ten thousand pound
respectively for these improvements
it is often the local community that is
best placed to identify a housing need
to help and encourage community projects
to meet these needs
we feel that the pre-application advice
for these
applications should be free ten thousand
pound has been allocated
for this communities have seen
unprecedented numbers of people turn to
food banks over the last year
unemployment data released to november
has shown a continuing
increase the rise is likely to continue
following the second wave as is the
number of people turning to support
while the cancer was done and continued
to do a great job in supporting our
residents we believe further support of
the cab and local food banks
will be required for the forthcoming
year
we are proposing a fifty thousand pound
grant to each
if coronavirus is a rainy day that we
should have been putting away for then
the climate and biodiversity crisis is a
hurricane just over the horizon that we
need to avoid
biodiversity is in serious decline
globally last year's living planet
report shows an
average 68 declining animal population
sizes since 1970
and the 2019 state of nature report
found 41
of uk species are in decline and 1 in 10
is threatened with extinction to enhance
biodiversity task force proposals
we are proposing further work in two
areas
an additional treat officer to
facilitate proactive management of trees
on cancer owned land and to protect more
valued and ancient trees with tree
preservation orders
and they will also ensure approved
planting schemes are carried out
and maintained as developments are
implemented
we then then feel there is a need for
dedicated biodiversity
officer to work with local communities
and businesses actually look for and
implement opportunities to increase
biodiversity in the district
it is imperative that we prevent further
biodiversity loss
and the officer will also look to
prevent this we are including a sum of
94 000
pounds to cover these two offices
we have mentioned many times that if
we're going to stand a chance of meeting
the council's climate commitments
then we need to facilitate a shift from
car dependency to travel by
foot bicycle and bus we also need to
target the energy used to heat and run
our
homes to reach carbon zero by 2030 we
need to both massively
a massive reduction in car use and a
massive switch to electric vehicles
we are therefore proposing a sum of
thirty thousand pounds
to allow installation of electric
charging points in our public car parks
including a pin meal
we are also recommended that when
charging is implemented in our car parks
that any electric
charging spaces are free while in use
in addition to this we would like to see
that all products generated from car
parking charges
once ongoing maintenance costs are
considered is ring fence for pub
for sustainable transport rather than
the proportion as
agreed we would like to see the council
undertake a zero carbon travel plan to
identify and cost the path of this
council to reach zero carbon travel by
2030
and use that plan to help identify
suitable uses of ring fence money and
other funding sources
we have allowed four thousand pounds for
an officer's time to complete this work
jumping back to amendment three it's
pretty cool that we improve
existing housing stock and move them to
carbon zero
we are proposing an officer be dedicated
to support the retrofit program of our
stock
to support a program of retrofitting
private homes
and to ensure new builds are built to
the highest environmental standards
40 000 has been allocated to this this
completes the amendments that we are
proposing for the general fund
which will come from the transformation
fund we support the creation of a
transformation fund
and given the urgency of the climate and
biodiversity crisis now is the time to
start transforming
thank you very much thank you councillor
jameson
can i have a seconder please
do i'll have a second to please yeah
i'll second him um
counselor counselor creswell yes thank
you chair
sorry i i couldn't find the button in
timer
i um oh so sorry i've been told
councillor lindsay's got to do it
uh yeah that is fine thank you thank you
sorry councillor lindsay please continue
uh could i could i reserve my right to
to speak later
of course you can yes thank you fine
thank you
thanks um so
the amendment has been seconded uh
council ward
do you accept this an amendment or any
element of it there were four elements
um no
these amendments fall into four broad
categories planning communities
environment
council could i ask you to turn your
camera off we're having a few problems
um with your with the transmission
um so it might help if you could turn
your camera off please
and that might stop the freezing that's
sometimes happening
okay okay yeah so um so
uh no um these amendments fall into four
broad categories planning communities
environment and housing and my cabinet
colleagues for each of those areas will
respond shortly
to each of those um items so um
now i'm afraid we don't accept the
amendments at the moment thank you
okay thank you so in that case um
we're going to have to debate on the
amendment
as i said the amendment um breaks into
four different categories as john
waters just said too counsellors will
be able to speak once for three minutes
and this will be timed so we're now
speaking to the amendment only um
is that counselor arthur have you got
your hand up
i have yeah thank you councillor arthur
would you like to
begin please okay um well
firstly i'll say that i actually agree
with many of the issues
that councillor jameson has has raised
and i appreciate
um that he's um taking the trouble to
cost all of the proposals but i don't
think this is the way to achieve them
um i would much rather see
some evidence behind what he sees
as the shortfall rather than just sort
of some
anecdotal comments and to me it seems
like these proposals have
kind of been plucked out of the sky
i'll address some of them um the first
one
i think is on page is it 88 where it
starts 89
89 which is planning enforcement
um and i don't think the way to address
this is just
to pull out a figure and put it in the
in the budget
um enforcement as i'm sure everybody
knows has been going through a
transformational period
um planning enforcement now um
under phil isbell team leader uh
simon bailey and if there's a need for
additional resource here
um that request should probably come
from simon
should go through phil should go through
tom and
ultimately that's tom barker and
ultimately the head of the paid service
is our chief executive
and how we provide the services that we
have to provide
is something that should be dealt with
by those people
who are providing them so um
if i just run through i don't know how
much i'll get through in my time
the training and advice for planning
committees i absolutely agree with that
again i don't think just throwing money
at it is the way to achieve it
um i will be having ongoing discussions
um
with tom barker and phil isbell about
what i think is a need for additional
training
some time ago when i was chairman of
committee which is about 15 or 20 years
ago
i think we had a more comprehensive
training regime than the one that we've
got now
so i'd be happy to explore um ways in
which we can
uh improve our training um the free
pre-application advice for community
needs again this looks as though it's
just
throwing money at something um i'm not
quite sure
whether offering free pre-app for any
community initiative
is actually the way to address things i
mean we could end up lining ourselves up
with a whole load of additional work
unnecessarily um for sort of um
not exactly frivolous um proposals
but just for you know sort of
investigative type stuff
um so i don't know whether that's the
the right way to
to attack that i'll comment on a few
others that don't come under the the
planning
portfolio while i've got 30 seconds left
okay
um i'll go on to ev charger points then
i don't think
the general fund is the way um to
increase the roll out of electric
vehicle charger points
um seal is a much better way to fund
that um we've already funded some of our
points through seal we've got six going
in in lavenham at the moment under a
seal bid
so i agree with the principles behind
everything that's been said but i don't
think that throwing money at it from the
general fund
is the way to achieve what lee um
thank you councillor gold
thank you madam chair um i
will be voting for the amendment because
i think
we cannot continue with business as
normal when climate change
and i'm quoting here david attenborough
who's been speaking on the news just
this very night
climate change is the biggest threat to
humanity's continued existence
that mankind has ever faced david
attenborough feels it's possibly too
late already
i hear what counselor arthur is saying
um that
perhaps there may be other ways of doing
these things
but but at some point we've got to stop
talking about it we've got to do
something
it's what we greens were elected for i
believe there are four greens on baby
district council now
and we do need to speak up for the
people who elected us
um and okay so perhaps the uh there
might be another way of addressing the
pre-planning issue but
well let's find the other way then let's
find the mechanism let's do it
let's start acting and let's start
acting as if climate change
is real before it's too late thank you
madam chair
thank you councillor gould council
malfeezy
thank you very much madam chairman and
before i start can i address the
biodiversity element
and parking in one or
do i get two shots no you get one shot
and this is it
okay thank you very much madam chairman
as both councillors know um we've got a
biodiversity action plan
and we can't really plant the wrong tree
in the wrong place because we need to do
a mapping exercise
to identify the right place for the
right tree so they both know that we've
got this going on now
and maybe they don't know that our
corporate manager who has the necessary
skills
um is liaising with taylor wimpey on the
chilton woods
on the biodiversity aspect of everything
it would be nice to have an additional
tree officer but we need to define
the need and determine the need because
we need to spend money and that money
would have to come from the
transformation fund
eevee charging capability we are
addressing it
we're doing solar carports kingfisher
let's leisure centers
and in a load of other places around
around
the district the joint local plan
requires that the supply cable
is taken up to the property
but they are not required to install ev
charging points and that really isn't
our job because it's up to individual
choice
do have a sustainable travel officer so
we don't need to go and
find another one the parking
we will be conducting a strategic
parking review
and that will address all the issues but
it takes
18 months to two years to come into
effect
to get to recommendation stage
the new tariffs will not make a profit
if there is anything left over it is not
considered a profit but it is to be ring
fenced
and used for sustainable transport and
other
travel options but as i said
both councillors know that this is in
the pipeline
it's part of what we discussed but i
would like to draw attention that the
solar carport project
for kingfisher has attracted 400
000 pounds active travel cycle storage
in sudbury 25 000
decarbonization of leisure centers
in hadley and
kingfisher amount to hundred and seventy
one thousand
so faber has been working
the second councillors have been working
i'm concluded madame chairman thank you
thank you councilman vc counselor john
osborne
thank you madam chairman i'm leaving my
video off because like john i have some
i.t problems today so um right on the
proposal
for an officer to be dedicated to
support the retrofit program of our
housing stock and discussions
is already taking place the level of epc
that homes will need to meet
is taking place in central government
and was subject to
consultation before kovid several months
ago
at baber we are ahead of the game
and we have already defined and funded
in the 2122 budget a role for an
energy efficiency surveyor to work with
the private sector
also we are looking at national grant
opportunities to attract funding to
support private landlords
and would like to support this further
with our own grant offer for
improvements to private rented
accommodation
so actually the amendment is the request
for this
is already um being accounted for
in the 2122 budget which is before us
today for approval
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor osborne
councillor davis
thank you chair yeah i'll just quickly
address the um
the communities issue in terms of the
funding for the cabs
um i'm sure uh other councils be aware
that we've already discussed
um given the cabs um
53 000 pound it was at the cabinet
briefing it was at the cabinet meeting
it was
overview and scrutiny and uh and so
again
as my other colleagues cabinet
colleagues have pointed out these things
are already being addressed
um we knew these questions were coming
up obviously but
we've also seen that uh mid-south that
it's it's remarkably similar amendments
to mid-suffolk
and the greens there withdrew theirs um
you know we're already dealing with this
so freely i i just want to reiterate
all counsellors are welcome to come to
the briefings are welcome to come to the
meetings both cabinet and scrutiny
and if they want to discuss things
they've got ideas we'd be more than
happy to listen to them
that's me thank you thank you councillor
davis
councilman crawl
thank you very much chair um i think in
some ways we're coming back to an
element of disconnect
uh the opportunities do exist i know
because i go to
nearly everything i possibly can and the
reason i can't support the
amendments is because well the three
reasons one
that as councillor atheist pointed out
there isn't an evidence base provided
we'd normally
use an evidence base for decisions i
it's my watch word
so these become wishes and you know in
some cases i'd happily support them if
we have the money
but we don't unlike mid-suffolk who do
have the money and yet the
amendments were withdrawn there i found
some disconnect in itself there
but more importantly and i think most
importantly the budget papers before us
today forecast
a series of gaps for the next three
years quite large ones
uh facing that in that light
using reserves for what has to be repeat
spending uh adding new stuff
extra offices is a repeat spend
that is going to take away from our
running costs and and our cap our
running costs for the future
and i don't think in these circumstances
that can be warranted
in fact our section 151 officer in
appendix b
of the papers before you on paragraph 28
on page 63 of the papers
specifically warns in our situation
against using reserves we are trying to
redress
a loss of reserves or a potential loss
of reserves
so in these circumstances there's no
reason there's no
sense frankly in committing ourselves to
increased regular spending for the
foreseeable future
and finally specifically the staff
complement
is a matter for the head of paid service
the chief executive
and all the directors and assistant
directors
and officers underneath them because
they are the ones who can best assess
the requirements politically we can ask
for these things we can suggest these
things the cabinet will do so
but we have to look at our overall
running costs because that is what a
budget is about
so i can't support any of these
amendments much as if i'd like to
because i believe they're entirely
worthy and a variety of areas citizens
advice food banks
all this stuff nice if we can afford it
we can't i'm afraid thank you council
mccraw
councilman mayberry
thank you very thank you very much
chairman um
i do have to say that i can't comment on
every single item
um on on this because of the reasons
already declared
um but i would like to say that i would
support additional planning enforcement
because i have actually had
cause to speak to enforcement um
in the last 24 hours
on a couple of occasions and i think
that they are doing a splendid
job and they actually do need some more
support
um some more facility uh in their
capacity so i would support that
um i never think that any training
is a waste of time you can always
glean something from from training so
that is also valid um
and to when we come to the free
pre-application advice for community
needs
we are emerging from postcovid and i do
remember that we were
promised a post covered plan which i
have not seen if there is one
please could someone send me a copy
because i think that
there will be a huge need within
communities
any community and this
may be a way of helping the
local communities and that can be
anywhere from
shockley through to sudbury through to
the north of of the area and even
even down to um east virgo so i would
support that as well
food banks this is the first time i've
ever seen
a comment about food banks
having some application of
finance from a district council here
and i must say i have always heard some
very negative
comments um about food banks
um and i know that the councillors know
who they are and i'm not going to
mention them at this point but i do
remember
visiting with certain members
food banks within the local area so i
would support
that as well another item that i would
definitely support
is an additional tree officer because i
will remember
in my time on the cabinet which i very
much enjoyed
and i did do my best and officers said
i did a really good job that we were
actually
short of capacity to help with tpos
and the removal of hedges during
planning applications
so i would support that too there are
some very valid points
and thank you for bringing it forward my
green colleagues
thank you
thank you councillor mayberry councillor
cresswell
thank you chair um i'd like to say thank
you to philly for
quite a good presentation and given me
some knowledge that i hadn't got
um and i agree with councillor gould
that
um i didn't see the david attenborough
thing but we all know
how fast we need to get things moving
regards
climate change we see the ice caps
melting
we hear things like the sea levels going
to raise we get um
where we talk um taylor wimpey and
chilton woods
where they're going to build 11 1200
homes
and uh probably use gas boilers gas
central heating which are going to go
which aren't meant to be used i think
those five years i may be wrong
and we need to look at alternatives and
for that reason i
i will agree with the amendments i think
green changes
are definitely needed thank you very
much
thank you councillor cruz well
councillor hinton
thank you very much chairman um there's
some very good points within this
amendment
but one of the things that they haven't
really in my opinion
grasped is where we can actually save
money on this to be able to finance some
of these initiatives
uh i had a quick look through the
through the papers uh
in preparation for this meeting and i
noticed that our
accommodation costs are going up by 128
000 next year
well with everybody working from home an
endeavor house probably
three-quarters empty uh why is it
costing us 128 000
more to have fewer people working in the
offices so there are
there is scope for some uh savings to be
made
as far as the green initiatives are
concerned i agree with the
the thoughts on tree offices and on
planning which protects
green initiatives like ancient hedges
and ancient trees
in actual fact the mppf already does
that but it seems to get ignored when it
comes to planning applications and they
tend to get
removed with remarkable ease and yet we
then make a big thing about planting
a tree for every newborn but that's a
little whip
if you're taking out 100 200 year old
oak tree there's a lot more carbon
stored up in that than there is in the
whip that's been put in
and it takes a long time for that whip
to actually produce any real meaningful
carbon savings
so we've got to get a a grip of these
sorts of things and to look at them in a
much more logical fashion
and throw out some of the dogma and look
at
reducing costs as well as providing
uh funding for other services
thank you councillor hinton um if there
are no other
people who want to join the debate um
i'll
invite councillor jameson
oh oh yes councillor lindsay
i believe you reserved your right to
speak did you
want to say anything um yes please chair
yes
thank you um yeah
i i i listened to all the
comments with a great deal of interest
um
but i can't help thinking that
everything that they've been saying
they've been forced to say these cabinet
members have been forced to come out and
say
this is what we're doing here this is
what we're doing there
by the fact that we've filed these this
motion
and you know frankly that's that's not
good enough
you know if we um what we're talking
about here is some very modest sums
we're not going to bankrupt the council
a few thousand there a few a few
thousand here
um what it's about is what it says about
our
priorities as a council and and if these
things aren't
spelt out in our in the budget that
that's brought before us that by this
cabinet then we have every right
to push for them and you know it's you
know
every anyone who who votes against these
this
amendment needs to ask themselves
are the cabinet members and the leader
doing enough on these all these things
all these items that we've mentioned
are they really going to happen um you
know we've heard
they're talking about oh it's okay our
officers are talking to taylor winfrey
about biodiversity
so that's okay but you know we know we
all know
our officers are overworked and
and you know every time we we're here on
the great fight
planning enforcement they're overworked
i can't keep up
um viability wasn't was skirted over
um by councillor alfie
but we need to hold developers
you know to the wall and say to them
when you when they say oh we can't we
can't afford this is not viable
we need the experience and the trained
staff
to be able to hold them to account say
well actually come on and haggle with
them and
and and actually force them to come up
with some benefits for the community
out of the profits they make out of
developments um
uh the cabinet members are saying it's
okay we'll leave it to our chief
executive to decide about staffing
but he's got a limited budget it's up to
the cabinet members
and the politicians to set the
priorities and one of the ways you can
do that is to say
come on have we really got enough staff
here chief executive
in this area of planning enforcement
have we got enough staff in biodiversity
given that that's one of our priorities
have we got enough staff
to tackle the climate crisis given that
we've said it's our priority
and really cross question that really
challenge that
and this is one way we're doing it so
i'd urge you to support this motion
because it ain't going to have a lot of
impact
on our reserves but it is going to have
an impact
on how the public and how the whole
council
views our priorities thank you
thank you councillor lindsay councillor
horan um you put your hand up rather
late is there something you wanted to
add
uh yes madam chairman um i did put up
early but it
it fell down again i think so my
apologies um
what are the problems of this technical
age i would just like to make
the point madam chairman to everybody
that um
if you're going to have a change of
direction uh you
need to be thinking about it over a long
period of time there's lots of
comment here but extra staff but maybe
we don't need extra staff
maybe we just need to divert some of the
staff we have
to doing different things i do find it
extremely odd that we have got
six members of staff i'm told across
baby mid suffolk
employed in the comms team
now i tend to think if you need six
members of staff
um trumpeting what you're doing maybe
we're not doing a very good job anyway
i'm not saying that those members of
staff could be
um put into the sort of work we're
talking tonight but in long-term
planning you need the right people doing
the right things
so it may not be employing extra people
it may be getting the people we've got
doing what we need them to do and this
could be one of the things we need to
spend
money where it's going to help us in the
future
that is my point i'll probably support
this motion just to get the numbers up
because um for god's sake we do need to
be doing something about this
we talk about lots of things um which
are important but this is most important
if we don't react um
it's going to kill us all so i will
support the motion
just to be damn minded i think thank you
chairman
thank you councillor harren so i'll
return now
to council jameson um as the proposal of
the amendment
is there anything else you wish to add
um only the term i find i was quite
disappointed to find that some members
can't see anything within these
amendments that are important enough to
spend money on
and the only other thing about to come
in clinton
council of melveezy which seemed to be
under the impression we were proposing
electric charging points on private
properties it was just
for our car parks and also we were not
looking for an
extra sustainability travel officer it's
just
um the time of some of the
sustainability officer's time
to um produce a travel plan
but um other than that no thanks chair
thank you council ward is there anything
else you wish to add
before we go to the vote yeah yeah just
um a couple of quick points
um firstly i want to say that we are
committed to our climate change
mitigation
objectives and the evidence this is
clear and we really are doing
as much as we can we care as much as the
greens
this budget amendment is a mixed bag
with some good ideas many things we are
already doing and a couple that have
merit boosting enforcement which we all
agree
and extra support for our biodiversity
action plan but there are others as
you've heard that are simply not needed
there's no evidence of any additional
need uh any need for additional funds
for the sudbury cab
they currently have a good financial
position and haven't asked for any more
similarly there's no evidence for the
need for a one-off grant for our food
banks
there are other funding sources
available to them apparently council
osborne offered some money from her
locality budget which was declined
we are in regular contact and we'll be
happy to support if necessary
we already give support as part of the
wider county response to covid
no food bank is lacking support and all
are well funded and organized
the associate directors can look at the
two that we could implement and decide
how they could be delivered and then
make requests for staffing requirements
to the head of paid service based on
need
the budget is not the place however for
determining this any cost that we may
incur in the current year
can be met from the transformation fund
that's all i'd like to say chair thank
you
thank you council ward so in a moment
we're going to be
voting on the amendments and we'll be
doing four votes taking them each as
separate items so we'll be doing that in
just a moment
in accordance with council procedure
rule
19.3 immediately after any vote is taken
at a budget decision meeting of the
council the names of councillors who
cast a vote for the decision
or against the decision or who abstain
from voting
shall be recorded in the minutes of that
meeting
i'm proposing that we take each element
of the amendment
separately
i will now ask the corporate manager of
governance and civic office
to conduct the recorded vote on part one
of the amendment
planning and community needs the
amendment can be found at page
89 in modern gov so vote 1
amendment part 1 planning and community
needs
madam chairman it's councillor mabry
here and i'm very sorry to interrupt you
but i would like some guidance as to
whether or not i'm able to vote on this
considering my declaration previously
that i am a director of citizens advice
monitoring officer thank you very much
[Music]
thank you chairman i believe councillor
mabry made a
local non-pecuniary declaration of
interest which means she is able to vote
on this amendment and on the budget
recommendations when we get to that part
of the debate and the vote
thank you chairman thank you
thank you very much for that advice
thank you we'll now move to the votes
thank you chair councillors can you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting the
voting tab for this agenda item will
show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the boat thank you
chair just clarification this is voting
on the amendment isn't it
that's correct only on the amendment not
on the whole paper
is to accept it or not the first element
of the amendment thank you thank you
chair
thank you
council of beer and councillor dawson
we're still awaiting your vote are you
okay or are you having technical issues
now mine's stuck
counselor dawson i can't even get to the
vote
okay would you like to vote manually
then would you like to say whether
you're voting for
amendment part one um planning and
community needs
for or against against thank you
and councillor beer are you able to vote
um unfortunately i cannot get the little
bar to slide up and down to move it i've
got it all in front but it won't allow
me to move the fin
to vote and so i'm voting against the
amendment
thank you very much thank you so
annoying
to do that
chair that the vote is 10 4 and 22
against part one of the amendment
thank you so that amendment is lost
we'll now move on to the next vote i'll
now ask the corporate manager
governor and civic office to conduct the
recorded vote on part two of the
amendment
which is on biodiversity and environment
thank you chair again councillors can
you open the vote in the modern.gov app
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting in
the voting tab
the vote for this agenda item will show
in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote and you may need to tab down to
find the blue line
thank you again i cannot make it go down
the blue line to appear or you can go
down it likewise dawson
okay i would um councillors if that's
the case would you like to
um to give your vote manually it's
ridiculous because it was working to
start with
um i'm against the amendment thank you
councillor beer and councillor dawson
against thank you
ah i think i got it working now
chair that is um the votes are 10 4 and
22
against thank you
so that element of the vote is
lost i'll now ask the corporate manager
governor and civic office to conduct the
recorded vote on part
three of the amendment which is on
housing
and climate change
thank you chair councillors if you go to
the top right hand side of the screen
and select attendance and voting
the voting tab will show blue please
click on the blue line to open the vote
thank you i think i got it working this
time
don't ask me why but it is coming up
uh is that photon item three sorry um
madame that is item three that's good
i'm talking to myself and trying to find
out uh
i've forgotten what i've got to do i've
gone into blue i've got to press that at
night
[Music]
ah yes there we go um perhaps the
officer can
chan uh dawson i'm against okay
thank you and councillor beer we have
yours now so thank you
[Music]
chair the voting is as follows 8 4 and
24
against the part 3 of the amendment
thank you
thank you so that amendment is lost
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to conduct the recorded vote on part
four
of the amendment which is on travel
thank you thank you chair again
councillors please can you open the vote
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the
agenda screen and selecting attendance
and voting
the agenda item will show in blue please
click on the blue line to open the vote
thank you councillor dawson gainst
okay thank you councillor dawson
um
[Music]
councillor hinton we're still waiting
for your vote are you having technical
difficulties or would you like to
give your vote manually
councillor hinton oh you got it thank
you we have your vote now thank you
thank you chair the voting for the
fourth element is
9 4 and 23 against thank you
[Music]
okay so that amendment is
is lost so we will now return to the
original motion
for questions and debate um
we will now move to questions first
counsellors may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question have we got
anyone who'd like to ask a question
please
this is on the original um paper
counselor fraser
thank you madam chairman um may ask a
question on clarification please
yes you may please do uh on the
main text page 43 paragraph
8.19 on the income
section there's a bullet stating about
the implementation
of short-term car parking charges
from october 2021 across the district
this um not precise it's a bit vague
uh we understood that uh parking charges
weren't going to be brought in
before october 21 but may i ask
um when a precise date would be decided
um so which state will parking charges
be implemented from
uh who would make this decision and what
would be the criteria
on setting the date please thank you
thank you council award are you going to
answer this
yes i can answer that um as council
fraser has has pointed out
it's a not before date and and it it's
not precise because we do not know how
things are going to develop this year it
it could be later than that
in which case the potential additional
income for this year
would be less than the amount specified
but we have to put a date and a figure
in the budget for for budgetary purposes
should the date slit should that number
um decrease
then that will be managed through the
regular quarterly
monitoring reports next year but in
terms of the
decision-making cabinet will obviously
make that final decision as to the date
and we'll take into account um an
assessment of
how our high streets our businesses
um are recovering as we go into the
summer and autumn
and it all depends on the success
of the uh the measures that the
government's taking to to ease lock down
um hopefully with a full um back to
normal on the 21st
of june so we will monitor this
carefully over the coming months and
and then make a decision thank
thank you has that answered your
question councillor fraser
yes thank you and i'm grateful for to
council award for that full explanation
thank you chairman thank you councillor
mayberry
thank you thank you chairman um my
question is
on the garden waste brown bins however
one would like to to
identify this um with the garden waste
refuse collection uh could
the portfolio holder confirm
that refunds because of the
non-collection
have been taken into account in in the
budget
as described on page
i've got page four out of 16.
thank you
yeah sorry yes they have been taken into
account
fine does that answer your question
counselor maybe
um depends when these figures um were
put in because obviously the brown bins
are not being collected at the moment
um and when i asked last week i was told
it would be another month
um brown bins will be collected all
things being equal week commencing the
8th of march
um this is a budget and therefore
budgetary figures
go in then we're not discussing actuals
thank you but that's really helpful for
me to be able to inform my residents
thank you
thank you thank you councillor dawson
um yes yes if i could just come back
to um the comments by john it'd be
really helpful to have real
clarification on this business about the
dates because
my understanding is that the tariffs are
going to come in on the 1st of october
and there's been no question about this
so it'd be really helpful if you could
just
really clarify if businesses and
councillors
particularly in hadley if we come to you
and half your group are asking you
not to introduce these tariffs can you
confirm that you won't be doing that on
the 1st of october
i i can't confirm anything of the sport
as i
as i said um the first of october is
is the not before date and it will
depend on the recovery
uh over the next few months and through
the summer and into the autumn
and we will take make that decision
based on
uh an assessment of business recovery
and that and that
uh i can't say any more than that i'm
afraid well if i could just come back on
that
um you know we've been saying all along
uh
because of kovi there's absolutely no
doubt about it the high streets in
hadley
and suddenly and all around the rural
communities
have really suffered and uh
i think you know very well we've been
very clear about the fact that
this never should have been introduced
the timing of this is really appalling
with the car parking
and uh you know having a cabinet the
problem is is you've got a few people
deciding on behalf of the majority
and uh you know i was one of the few
people five years ago who was very anti
voting for a cabinet because
they don't it's not representative of
everybody
so i'm going to the point to make a
question
yes so i would really like to try and
drill this down with you
we asked for a deferment on the tariffs
and this was declined and there's no
doubt that the cabinet haven't listened
to uh the request to have this deferred
so what is your criteria for first of
october
whether you go ahead or not go ahead is
it going to be officers
or is it going to be the same few people
that make the decision because there's
certainly no consultation on this at all
uh council dawson and we're discussing
the budget not not
parking um but uh as i said
the we we have actually compromised on
this we pushed the date back
as a result of um uh feedback and as a
result of um
the report from the overview and
scrutiny committee so there has been
some compromise
um i can't say any more than what i just
said earlier and asked it to council
fraser and
um quite honestly i i i can't say
anything more now
decision how it's going to be done the
decision will be made by cabinet based
on an assessment of the recovery
that's that's um as i said to council
fraser
but we're not here to discuss parking
we're here to discuss the budget let's
just follow on
councillor fraser's question may i just
ask
um cancer ward um how you'll be
measuring that
recovery well that's an eye vas um
we haven't um uh worked that out yet um
but uh we'll let members know once
that's
you'll let us know you'll inform members
thank you
thank you councillor huron
chairman thank you sorry to be a bit
slow on the buttons but um
i i was also going to raise that point
madam chairman because i do feel
strongly that um car parking charges
should not have been brought in in um
the upcoming financial year i think
let's get a grip on this
um i know there's going to be various
studies and
things done but i would have liked to
had a clear year
and i've made this point to john i don't
know if he wants to comment on it now
but i think that would be clean and um
give us a lot more credibility as well
to have a year without them
i know it's got the money's got to come
from somewhere and i'm well aware of
that
and i do tend to think that car parking
charges are not going to raise much
revenue for us anyway
so uh leave it alone for a year would um
would please this canton a lot of people
as well
a couple of general questions on the
paper as well
um once again on page 43 third bullet
point down
i see we'd be charged another 43
000 for service charges for endeavour
house
and in my view john that tends to be
gone the wrong way as we haven't been
there and the windows don't need
cleaning and um
not so much sweeping up and things i'm
just i know john is going to ask a
separate question as well about
um another matter on this but i'm asking
this one
why is it going up when i think really
it should be going down
and quickly maybe one for um councillor
malveezy on the transport just below
um there's something about it it's going
to cost
64k um no i'm wrong one
uh yeah the hydrated vegetable which i
was told was going to be cheaper and
less
engine maintenance and yet that's um
attracting another 88k on the budget and
i was very surprised at this because in
the
um press reports that were put out we
were told there's a saving on the fill
and a saving on engine maintenance and
in the budget it's um 88
um k more so clarification on those two
points please
and i think there were three in fact i
think it was the first one
yeah the first one was the first one was
a comment on the parking which um
was a point of view the other two are
straight questions um
thank you okay thanks i i won't comment
any more on parking
um it's not the the place for parking
uh the parking debate um in terms of the
uh
hydrogenated vegetable oil um
hydrate tree oil to use is correct
um the fuel is more expensive than
diesel there is a price differential
that varies
um and that 88 000 pounds is an average
of that price differential
so it is the more expensive fuel but as
i said in my introduction
our transport cost savings uh will
largely compensate for this in in the
first year but it's
um it's a green measure and green
measures um many of them
do come at a price and um and we have to
accept those prices as as um
as part of uh going green because for
this
this particular saving the the the
carbon reduction
is it's the biggest component of our
carbon footprint and it will have a huge
effect on on our ability to meet our
climate um
commitments in terms of endeavor house
um i understand we
the first few years of occupancy were at
a discount
um and that's now ended um and we didn't
uh agree increments at the start of the
lease
and the 43 000 pounds reflects those
increments
um but i do believe that uh there are
some uh budget negotiations in place i
don't know if the chief executive would
uh
like to comment further on this uh at
this point
um just for further clarification for
for councillor haran
thank you we have our chief executive
here thank you madam chairman
and thank you council award uh yes i can
just confirm that we are having
those conversations with suffolk county
council uh to try and negotiate that
back down
uh caster ward is absolutely right the
reason for the increase is because we
did a fantastic deal when we moved in
and we had a discounted rate for the
first two years that that was always due
to come
to an end at this point and we are in
addition to that
exploring whether or not as a result of
the the excellent working that we've
been able to do
throughout the covert crisis working in
a much more agile more remote way
we believe we won't need as much space
within endeavour house
for the future so we are exploring
whether it be possible to reduce our
floor plate
full template as a result which clearly
would have a knock on impact not just in
terms of service charge but also in
terms of rent
yes okay i'm going to just thank arthur
for that we have
we have discussed this before and um i
look to be um
regularly briefed on this situation
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor haran councilman
avery
thank you very much chairman um first of
all
i i would like to say that um
the discounts on endeavor house were
thanks to
um councillor jenkins um i am reminded
um i would like to ask
a question on appendix d
page four under sustainable communities
i was first shocked
and then absolutely delighted because it
appears that our chief planning officer
earns 1 million hundred and twenty two
thousand
so congratulations to him um but if
someone could confirm
that that is his salary thank you
uh have we got someone here who can
uh yeah um if i can pass that over to
um one of the finance team um
i've found the particular page that
counselor maybe
is referring to but um oh we have
catherine steele here
i think that's the whole thing the whole
planning team to be quite honest rather
than the chief planning officer
catherine thank you chair yes you're
absolutely right uh council award it is
for the whole team
that uh it works under the chief
planning officer not just him
thank you um if i may come back um
chairman
um having looked through
appendix d uh this is the only
officer that um declares that they
uh that they are
head of services because every other
item
is under something that we would that we
would actually understand
such as building control well there's a
group of people
economy and business there's there's a
group of people
so i'm i must say that i think that that
needs rewording
another year but i must say i do send my
congratulations to our chief planning
officer
for earning that amount of money um and
not compromising myself but i could
become his very best friend but i'm not
putting myself in a compromising
position but
well done to him and i might speak to
him tomorrow
thank you
thank you i think we'll move quickly on
from there
um councillor holt
uh thank you chet um i was just gonna go
back to parking to a certain extent to
try and
put some clarity certainly from an
economic team point of view
and just try and reassure members that
um we will be working closely
with both chamber of commerce in hadley
and sudbury
um and certainly the town centre manager
in sudbury
and and i really like to encourage all
members to feedback to myself and the
economic team of anything locally
and we have a road map now out of
recovery set by government yesterday
and i think it's important that we
acknowledge that really the recovery is
not going to start until the summer time
um and i think it would be naive of us
to try and put any sort of date on it i
think what we've got at the moment
is from october the first it makes
perfect sense
um we're just going to have to see how
that recovery goes see how
how our high streets do perform in the
coming months and gauge
where where we sit perhaps october
november
personally i think it may well be into
the new year when we see
uh recovery to a point when parking
charges may be introduced or maybe
implemented
but i just want to try and reassure
members that the economic team will be
working closely
with the both chamber of commerce um and
the town councils actually
uh to just gauge how we are all doing
how the high street's doing
and how all our businesses are doing
thank you
thank you councillor halt i think
members will appreciate uh that
information
uh councillor barrett
have you questioned
yes thank you uh madam chairman um yes
the debate has
sort of kicked off a little bit about
the press
um and i was going to just just ask
about that um
and um it pleased to hear that there are
there are
discussions taking place to um
find a a a suitable solution to the
rising costs of those premises um
can you tell us uh can someone tell us
how long a rental agreement
uh you're going to enter into and
if we don't get an agreement that's
satisfactory
um is that likely to mean moving to
alternative offices
um we have our qf executive here to
answer those questions yes i'm not sure
where the council award wanted to but
i'm more than happy to try and answer
that
so we're already in a lease arrangement
that is a binding contract that our
lease runs for 10 years
and and you can see that we therefore
have some some period to run until the
end of that lease period
there is however a break clause at the
halfway point so after five years
and so the conversations that we've been
having with the county council
are mutual conversations you feel like
alongside that contract
uh if the county council wished to do so
they could enforce that contract
and we would have to pay that service
fee but we have good relationships with
our county council and we're more mature
and more sensible
than simply relying upon a contractual
arrangement so the agreement that we
would enter
into would be a variation to the
existing agreement
and so would amend the service charge
for this initial period of time what it
doesn't do
is change the length of the lease in any
ratio of performance nor does it change
the brake clause
in that way shape or form said no we're
not exploring the use of any other
accommodation at this point in time
because we are contractually bound
as i say to the county council in line
with the agreement reached by this
council
back in 2016.
thank you thank you
councillor mayberry have you got a
question
i i have and thank you thank you
chairman i'm i
do beg your pardon i was hunting for the
page number but i still can't find it
um there is a comment um within the
paper
um paperwork for the budget that the
public
realm contract which has not been um
agreed yet that there's been an an
allowance for it uh could someone
actually
confirm to me what the allowance is and
how this has been taken into account in
the budget please
thank you councilman visa would you want
to answer this one
oh cassandra hello sorry i was just
switching my buttons off but yeah
and cassandra is here as well
bye absolutely thank you very much jared
thank you for the question i thought i'd
just jump in
um as i'm a little bit closer to the
finances so essentially the
um originally the budget last year
showed the cost of what the id verdi
contract
was for and the figure that is in
the budget before you today is based on
the paper that came
to cabinet around the decision to bring
that contract back in house at the end
of it
so the work that was done by the team
that um
are managing this project um are working
that on the basis that we will be able
to run that service for the same cost as
what the id verdi contract
previously cost so when we originally
were looking at this so we were it
looked as if it could be more expensive
to bring it back in house
however the the the people both overview
scrutiny and at cabinet were saying that
actually the control back and the
flexibility
and the increased service standards were
worth that and so the decision was taken
however as that project has progressed
it does look um
increasingly like we're going to be able
to do that within
the previous budget that was set and
that's what's in the paper before you
today
thank you may i come back um chairman
yes please do um my my other question is
does that actually include
um the vehicles the service vehicles
that will be needed for this project
so there is some capital purchases that
that need to be made
and the figure that's in there includes
the cost of those so there will be some
borrowing around that um but we also
clearly we own a number of our own
vehicles anyway and they were on
a program uh to be um
uh you know through the lifespan when
they need to be replaced
uh so there's a combination of what was
already due to be replaced and a
combination of some borrowing
and and if my third and last question
chairman if i may
is and these new vehicles that will be
purchased and the ones that we have at
the moment
what fuel will they be using we will
absolutely endeavor to
look for alternative fuels to diesel um
clearly all of our
um diesel vehicles will be moving to
hvo however if we do have the
opportunity to purchase electric
sooner then that's what we would look to
do
thank you i should look forward to
seeing the figures next year thank you
thank you councillor hinton have you a
question
yeah question for going back a bit just
one step in actual fact of the chief
executive
he mentioned a break clause at five
years well by my calculations that five
years is now
so can we is it possible for us to
exercise that break clause or are you
just going to roll it on to the next
five years um and take it from there
because when we made the original
decision we made it in the september
uh of one year but we hadn't even agreed
a contract until the february of the
following year so
i just wondering when the decision
actually started from
thank you council henson and if i can
share um
so the the decision was as you say was
made in 2016 however we moved in and the
contract
was entered into from october november i
forget which month
2017 so it's five years from 2017
so we haven't yet reached to that point
and i believe i'm right in thinking that
there is a
six month notice period so we haven't
yet reached the point of
needing to serve notice uh clearly
that's a conversation that we would have
with the cabinet
uh nearer the time uh clearly we
wouldn't leave it to six months before
because if we wish to exercise
uh six months to leave we need somewhere
else to go to but i've had no
indications from councillors that that's
something
that they would wish to explore uh that
for all the reasons that we moved into
endeavour house in the first place
councilman avery have you got a question
come back
on that sorry uh chair um um in response
to councillor hinton
um you've got to remember that uh this
isn't a decision for baber alone uh this
is a decision for both councils
um because any any move
from endeavour house would have a
financial impact on on two councils
and um we need to make sure that
whatever we did
um was uh not going to increase the
costs for either one or both of us
and indeed if it to increase the cost of
one it would be for both so um
we have to bear that in mind thank you
council award
council maybe did you have a further
question yes um
thank you uh this is part comment part
question
to the chief executive to help him out
i am very reminded that it was september
2017 that we moved into endeavor house
so would a month make a complete
difference to breaking the contract
and the second is if
for any reason um mid suffolk said
they wish to leave endeavour house and
baby said
they wish to stay or vice versa what
would happen
please um in terms of the month making a
difference it will be the date that's on
the contract and i believe the date on
the contract is october
but yes it's around that period of time
in terms of what would happen
i'm afraid my crystal ball is broken in
that regard
it would be something we would have to
look at carefully but clearly
what you have is a combined workforce
you don't have baber employees
separate from mid-suffolk employees so
as council award indicated
i would suggest it needs to be a joint
decision as to whether to to leave or
whether to stay
and that's not to say that you couldn't
look to relocate the council chamber of
course
that is something that is entirely at
baber's disposal
but you would have to incur separate
costs to the creation of that and
clearly
mid-suffolk's not going to subsidise the
creation of a of a separate uh
hadley or or sudbury for the sake of
argument uh council chamber
but that's something that clearly the
leader in the cabinet and other
councillors would
want to take a view on in due course and
we would also want to reflect on the
fact that
our way of working has completely
changed so whilst we all have
the backdrop of the council chamber
behind us clearly none of us are in it
and our hope is that the government is
going to agree
to lots of local government lobbying
that's going on at the moment
to enable councils to have the choice as
to whether or not they wish to return
when they can safely do so to
face-to-face in-person meetings
or whether they wish to remain holding
virtual meetings or a combination of the
two
depending on the circumstances and
clearly that will play into no doubt
some of the discussions that that may
need to be had
thank you com has it answered your
question councillor mayberry
um it has but unfortunately it's led to
several more questions
um can we move on to
um another counsellor first yes
absolutely
thank you councillor hinton
thank you madam chairman yes just to
come back on that well i just would
remind the
chief executive when it comes to joint
workforces that
uh the workforce might be joint but
we're two completely separate
constitutional and financial bodies
yeah so um
yes uh arthur if you'd like to answer
that and then um yeah i was going to
give a brief answer um
and only a brief answer and and equally
saying clearly we're moving
well away from the from the budget
debate which is which i think the
chairman was about to say herself but
just to give a
brief answer yes absolutely officers
including myself are fully aware
of the sovereignty that's why we go
through two lots of meetings
uh such as this uh having having uh had
the
full council for uh budget debate for
mid-suffolk last week so
we are consciously aware every single
day of the fact that we serve two
sovereign authorities
but i would repeat the fact that the
staff work for both uh and
unless you want them to sit in two
places uh and even in those
circumstances they can't be in two
places at once
and so i would suggest to all
councillors that it would not be logical
to go back to a situation where you have
two separate council buildings
in different places because it would
incur additional costs
but also provide no additional benefit
to your residents
thank you so while this has been most
interesting and um and helpful
we are can i remind everyone that we are
just here this evening to discuss the
budget
um so has anyone got any more questions
regarding the bucket papers please
if there are no more questions on the
budget papers we can now move on to
debate would anyone like to open debate
on the budget please
if no one wishes to open up question
open up the debate we could move
straight to
the vote
council award oh councillor arthi
would you like to um i reserved my
rights
yes you did indeed at the end if we
really haven't got anybody else
not at the moment okay um well
the the comments i wanted to make really
are um around
councillor jameson's proposed amendments
um and much of what he um had to say
there
as i said at the time i didn't disagree
with um so i just wanted to reassure him
that we will be monitoring the
enforcement team performance
um he may not know but the team is now
back up to full
strength as of as of this week they were
one down
up until the end of last week um we will
be looking at
additional planning training um i can
reassure him of that um from my point of
view although it's not my portfolio
um i do agree that we may well have a a
need
um building up for an additional tree
officer
um and we'll be looking at resourcing
that and
lastly i absolutely support his ambition
for the rollout of ev charges
um he's the district councillor for
lindsay
and lindsey parish council meet in the
village hall um and
his attended meetings there and i think
um was a great supporter of the fact
that we were
one of the first um i think the first
village hall in in baber
to install ev charger points
um so yes the the rollout of ev charges
in our car parks and our community
buildings
um supported via the sill framework that
as i'm sure he knows
allows 100 funding of green
infrastructure
um only 75 of non-green infrastructure
if you like so we make a special
concession
for green infrastructure which applies
to the installation of vv charger points
and i join with him in hoping that we
quickly
managed to increase the numbers across
the district
that's all i wanted to say thank you
councillor arthur
um councillor barrett did you want to
say something to
add to some debate um yes i i was going
to as
as we're having problems um starting a
date at all um i was just going to say
that um
um i i i think it's a shame that i
we're not going to be able to separate
out um
an issue like the parking charge from
the
general fund budget um
uh i i voiced my concerns many times
about
imposing these parking charges at the
time of the
when we're undergoing the effects of a
pandemic on the economy and on the
health of the nation but i've got little
choice but to
because because i can't separate those
two issues out
so um i you know i'm i'm happy to
um uh endorse the the the general
budget and i'll be voting for it thank
you
thank you councillor barrett if there's
nothing else that anyone
else would wish to add um i'll ask
councillor ward if there's anything else
he'd like to
say council award
yeah uh thank you chair i'm just trying
to get my cameras back on good
um just just a few words um uh
i'd like to endorse everything counselor
arthur has just said about um
uh that what we're doing um on on the
green infrastructures
uh funded by sil which um i think is
going to have
a significant benefit to our communities
but in conclusion this hasn't been an
easy budget but we have taken
difficult decisions in the best
interests of the district consequently
we are in a reasonable financial
position this year with a healthy level
of reserves
and we have been helped by the funding
we have received from the government to
mitigate the impact of covet
but as i've said the median turn
challenge is still significant as we
strive to become self-financing
through maximizing our income streams
supported by efficiency improvements
productivity savings and new ways of
working
finally it was gratifying to see a
couple of weeks ago that the local
government finance settlement
which was generally seen to be a good
one passed through parliament without
opposition
i hope that this spirit of pulling
together during the current pandemic is
replicated here this evening
thank you chair thank you council ward
so we're about to move to the vote
on this paper i'll just remind members
of the recommendations
so 3.1 is
that the general fund budget proposals
for 2021
22 and four-year outlook set out in the
report
be approved 3.2
that the general fund budget for 2021-22
is based on an increase to council tax
of five pound per annum
tempe per week for band d property
which is an equivalent of 2.96 percent
3.3 that the flexible use of capital
receipts strategy at appendix e
be approved 3.4
subject to approval by council notify
the ministry of housing communities and
local government
of the adoption of the strategy
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to conduct the recorded vote thank you
thank you chair councillors can you open
the vote in the modern dot gov screen by
clicking on the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting the
voting for this agenda item will show in
blue please click on the blue line to
open the vote
and cancellers you may need to tab down
the page to find the blue line thank you
a chance counselor dawson i'm afraid
mine's still stuck it won't move
okay councillor would you like to
indicate how you would like to vote
please
yes for thank you
councillor hinton are you um able to
vote please
thank you chair and the voting is 23 4
8 against and one abstention thank you
so uh the vote is carried
um i'm sorry to intervene can i can i
make a point of order please
yes um my understanding has always been
that a budget vote is a recorded vote
yes it is i just wanted to know uh
where will this be recorded um so that
members and the public may see how
everybody voted on the budget it will be
recorded in two places
it will be recorded in the minutes um
and it will be recorded
on the council's website thank you very
much chair
um now we've reached the point in the
meeting where we need to
um discuss as as members
about the guillotine um so can
if everyone is happy um i was planning
to
have a an adjournment of the meeting now
uh for five five minutes or ten minutes
five minutes
and um if all if everyone agrees
we will then continue the business after
the five-minute adjournment
is everyone happy to carry on with the
meeting
to finish the business if you're not
happy can you tell me now please
fine in that case we'll take a five
minute break
and we'll come back at um
quarter past eight
um we'll continue with the business at 8
15.
thank you members
welcome back to the meeting members will
now
continue with the agenda
item nine bc
2025 housing revenue account
2021 budget
and four-year outlook i would like to
invite councillor ward
to introduce paper bc 2025
and to move the recommendations in the
report
again i'm minding to allow council ward
and councillor jameson
the proposal of the amendment and their
seconders
longer than the time normally allowed in
these circumstances
all other councillors will have three
minutes
thank you council ward thank you chair
um you'll be pleased to know i i won't
need um anywhere near the
same amount of time as i took for the
general fund
so uh without further ado i'm pleased to
introduce report bc
2025 for the 2021-22 hra budget and
four-year outlook
because both the revenue account and
capital program
i'm sure you'll be pleased to know this
is going to be much shorter as i said
we have a sound 30-year business plan
which will support our ambitions to
increase our housing stock and which
continues to deliver favorable positions
for both revenue and capital
we've been helped by the ending of the
annual 1 rent reduction imposed by the
welfare reform and work act
2016. the act now allows rates to be
increased by cpi plus one percent for
five years from 2020 to 21.
the remaining 25 years of the business
plan are based on an annual rent
increase of cpi only
the business plan is attached to
appendix b and shows detail for years 1
to 10.
the new business plan will be presented
to cabinet and council during this year
as explained in paragraph 4.2 the plan
will include the need to invest
in the existing housing stock for
environmental improvements and safety
enhancements
and to build new homes that meet the
draft design guide and an improved new
build specification
we are continuing with our aspiration to
increase our housing stock
new homes of all types provide us with
new homes bonus and council tax
but additional council housing also
delivers rental income and wider
financial and social benefits
curved 19 has had a major impact this
year construction was halted for a
period
and property repairs and maintenance
were reduced for to emergency repairs
only
however void work in order to support
the accommodation of the homeless and
rough sleepers continued
and the renovation of the lees in a
matter of days was an excellent
excellent example of what we were still
able to achieve
i think you're you um
froze there could you please turn your
camera off
thank you just could you just turn it
off go back a sentence
i think you might have frozen for all
all members
levels of debt to be written off are
expected to be very low
as any outstanding rents are likely to
be reclaimed but over a longer period of
time because of the commitment the
council made not evict any tenants in
which renter is could
be contributed to covered therefore
there is no adjustment to rental income
collection and any impact will be
recovered by the strategic priorities
reserve
with recovery continuing in future years
a small amount of direct code related
cost has been incurred
47 000 pounds for ppe but this has been
covered from our general
uh from our government covered support
there has been no specific support
for the hra from government yet the
details of the budget presented in
section 5 of the report
table 1 and paragraph 5.2 summarizing
the key elements
and the movements from the 2020 to 21
budget
a surplus position of 127 000 pounds is
forecast
which is a reduction on last year's
figure of 334 000 pounds
we are proposing to transfer the surplus
to to the strategic priorities reserve
the budget has been based on a number of
assumptions the income ones that affect
our tenants being
a 1.5 rent increase which represents an
increase of 1.35 on the average weekly
rental of
91.70 garage rents will be unchanged
there will be an increase of 69 pence a
week for sheltered housing charges
and utility charges will be unchanged
other movements are explained in
paragraph 5.5
the largest contribution to the reduced
surplus is the inclusion of 967 thousand
pounds of
depreciation resulting from a
revaluation of the housing stock
however loan repayments will reduce by
350 000 pounds
due to one of our public works loan
board loans being repaid and full by
june
also highlighted here are the key
achievements this year the most notable
being that voice remain at an average of
18 days
and an excellent effort by building
services has resulted in the work in
progress
reducing from 7500 to 1500 outstanding
jobs
i'm also pleased that we now have that
we now have an operational hub for
building services at the great whiteham
depot
paragraphs 5.6 5.9 reports show the
predicted movement in the reserves
the ambitious capital program will will
require funding of 2.617 million pounds
from the strategic priorities reserved
as well as additional borrowing the
result will be a reduction in the
overall reserves balance to still
healthy 12.167 million pounds table six
in section 5.10 of the report summarizes
the capital expenditure and financing
for the next four years up to 2024 to 25
and the payments they provides more
detail the differences between the two
sets of figures is explained by the
current year carry forward has been
included in the appendix
new bills and acquisitions are forecast
to be 24 million pounds over this period
including a carry forward from the
current year
we have worked successfully with icini
to identify sites and are now proposing
an additional 161 affordable
and 44 shared ownership homes in the
period uh 2021 to 24.
and finally i'd like to note that right
to buy sales have again shown a further
reduction and are lower than those
projected in the business plan
in 2019-20 baba sold 11 against an
original projection of 20 sales
we have been delayed by covert in our
ability to use the right to buy receipts
before deadlines
for returning unspent portions to
government however the government has
extended the deadline to 31st of march
in recognition of this
we have looked at all opportunities to
acquire houses or land before this
deadline
and i am pleased to report that we will
have spent it all
and more by the deadline and so won't
have to return any to government
so i'd like to propose the
recommendations in paragraph 3.1 to 3.7
and ask for a seconder thank you
thank you councilwool can i have a
seconder please counselor john osborne
thank you madam chairman i i would like
to second this and i
would like to speak i don't know if i
speak now or do i speak after the
amendment
you you can do either you may speak now
i'd like to speak now then if i may
yeah okay right thank you thank you
madam chairman
i would like to thank my fellow cabinet
member for finance for his introduction
to the hra budget for the year 2122
as the cabinet member for housing i am
fortunate to see firsthand the work of
the housing service each day
only last week i read a letter from a
former rough sleeper
that had nothing and no one who is now
living in settled accommodation and
wanted to express his thanks and
appreciation to all those staff
from this council that have helped him
achieve this
the income the hra receives is
invaluable in supporting our tenants by
ensuring their homes are safe
and decent and places tenants are proud
to call
home the work of our team supports
tenants
to not only manage and maintain their
tenancies but support them to succeed
and thrive
this year as with many council services
the impact of the kovid pandemic has
impacted on the housing service
however officers have continued to
provide exceptional services
adjusting to working in new ways and
finding opportunities to maintain
service delivery and develop new ways of
working which have made services even
more efficient as set out in this report
this report demonstrates our investment
in a further 194
new homes planned over the next three
years along with capital improvements to
our existing homes over the short term
these capital works support our tenants
homes being decent safe
warm secure and inviting in strong and
healthy communities
an example of this investment includes
additional fire detection and fire
safety
asbestos removal and improvements to
homes
our hr business plan to be presented
later this year will provide
insight into our medium and long-term
investments in our homes
taking into account our responsibility
and duty in relation to fire and
building safety
ensuring homes are decent as well as
being affordable and economical to run
provide a high level of energy comfort
and ensuring how homes meet
legislation already set for example
the government's aim that all social
housing will be epcc
or above by 2030
this budget and our continued effective
management of the housing revenue
account
makes us well placed to meet all of our
aims and aspirations
as portfolio holder for housing i would
like to take the opportunity to second
this report
and the recommendations set out with it
in paragraph three
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor osborne
now we do have um an amendment to this
paper
um members if you'd like to look at page
105
of your papers that's where you'll find
the amendment
i would like now like to invite
councillor jameson
to propose the amendment from the green
group
council jameson okay thank you madam
chair
excuse me we've set out this amendment
to help us to ensure that our residents
have healthy secure warm housing
and to help us meet the commitment made
to achieve net zero carbon emissions by
2030.
many councilmen residents on low income
who are living in polyungrated homes
with older inefficient heat systems
are experiencing fuel poverty or are
close to it the latest figures although
three years old show that the proportion
of uk households in fuel poverty is ten
percent
in 2017 figures showed the average for
suffolk was also 10
and baba was even worse at 12 or 113
houses
after the effects of last year this
could be worse
the uk housing stock limits on average
four tons of co2 a year
which is a significant contribution to
the overall missions the country
produces in 2019
it was reported the homes that homes
contribute to 15
of the total uk emissions in proposal
2.2 of the council's carbon reduction
plan we are committed to seek the
resources to
assess the environmental performance of
our housing stock and in proposal 2.3
we state that we will implement the
program of upgrades to heating systems
in candles cancel stock replacing oil
systems
wherever possible and prioritizing heat
pumps where appropriate
it's been confirmed to us that the as a
council of budget said
officers are developing a housing
revenue account business plan which we
set out
our ambitions and financial commitments
in the medium and long term
in fact the council was committed to
undertaking a lot of work over the next
18 months and has secured green homes
funding that will allow us to improve
installation
insulation and install s or heat pumps
into 38 homes further funding is
expected to extend this
to another 100 homes this is all good
and it's pleasing to learn that so much
work is underway
however we are developing a strategy as
mentioned earlier that is based on
around improving
epc ratings of properties as proposed by
the government
however epc ratings are not necessarily
the answer for improving energy
efficiency
as a passive house can have a worse epc
rating than a house with gasoline
treating
but produces a third of the emissions
uh energy emissions of gas of the guess
sorry of the gas heat house
so firstly if we are developing a
strategy we need to ensure it is the
correct strategy strategy to meet our
carbon
commitments it is possible to make
houses zero carbon but a cost the cost
is not small
the costs have recently been averaged at
twenty thousand pound per house
a total cost of seventy million to this
council clearly we will need to borrow
and bid for any money we can in the
years ahead to raise this kind of summon
but we need to make a serious start now
in the coming financial year
if we as a council don't show our
commitment why would a donor body award
us a grant
to help the housing team make progress
in retrofitting our house in stock
we propose that two million pounds made
available from the 12 million pound
housing revenue reserves
this money can be used in the first
place to ensure we are following the
correct strategy
and to help speed up price the process
the council is already undertaking
of identifying the hardest to heat homes
against amongst its stock
once we have done that we can then
prioritize houses that will give
us the biggest carbon biggest saving in
carbon emissions
and heating bills for the lowest outlay
at twenty thousand pound
house this money can allow us to fully
retrofit a hundred properties
a small percentage of our total stock
admittedly but used wisely this could
reduce the carbon emissions of many more
i am sure
to reduce fuel poverty and to meet the
commitment of carbon zero by 2030
we need a massive reduction in carbon
emissions from our homes
to do this in one goal go is not
feasible without a huge loan
we can however as they say eat the
elephant one by a time
thanks a lot thank you councillor
jameson
can i have a secondary please
yes oh yes
councillor lindsay yes thank you thank
you council lindsay did you want to
speak now or did you want to wait
um could i wait please yes certainly
um council ward do you accept the
amendment
uh no chair i don't and i think council
osborne will um
have something to say and explain why in
a bit thank you okay
thank you so in that case we will move
to
debate on the amendment counselors will
only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
so we'll now move to uh debating the
amendment
okay uh councillor mabry were you
wishing to
start the debate yes i i will and thank
you and thank you chairman
um first of all i i will declare that
i am the owner of a an air source heat
pump
so i deliberately
made a choice that i would not be using
fossil fuels
um if the uh if the monitoring officer
would like to say now if i can continue
speaking or whether that's classed as a
pecuniary interest
please
thank you madam chairman i'm happy to
confirm that that's not a pecuniary
interest
so you are at liberty to continue
councillor mabry thank you thank you
very much
for that um i
absolutely agree that this is the way to
go
if we are trying to reduce our fossil
fuels
are carbon emissions then um heat source
pumps whether they are air or
ground are obviously the the way to go
but coupled with that we do actually
need
very good insulation very high grade
insulation
and i am reminded of a
development that i visited in devon
which was built
on the very edge of a
an estate that was bordering onto
one of the moors and these
were very highly insulated properties
and they did not use fossil fuels
they are absolutely amazing i have
shared these photographs many times with
um planning officials they are just most
amazing properties
and i think that we apart from
retrofitting we
need to move forward with all our
housing with
very high insulation better
heating systems which do not involve
fossil fuels i am trying to um
persuade the developers at chilton woods
that this is the way to go
um they are resisting at the moment but
i am determined
that i will get to the end of fossil
fuels
especially on new developments but we do
need to retrofit
as well thank you thank you council
maybe
councillor john osborne thank you madam
chairman
as i say again i'm keeping my video off
because i do have got some i.t
problems currently work is taking place
by officers to
develop a revised housing revenue
account business plan
which will set out our ambitions and our
financial commitments in the medium and
long term
we expect to bring this work forward
during the summer and we will ensure the
development of our plans involve all
members
through meaningful involvement
consultation and including a workshop
we know a recent housing survey has put
the cost of decarbonisation at
twenty thousand seven hundred and forty
two pounds per property
whilst the figures provided by the
social housing sector range from
three thousand to fifty thousand per
home
for us the cost could be up to seventy
million
whilst we know that the cost of retrofit
in the social housing sector
is estimated nationally at 104 billion
it is for these reasons that i do not
see any benefit to creating a specific
reserve for our hra housing stock
in relation to retrofit and
sustainability
especially when the required investment
is so significant in addition to the
whole landlord service
and all the initiatives we wish to
undertake to improve our services for
tenants
as i set out a recent cabinet meeting in
response to a question
our work on the development of our
business plans requires a
transformational approach
which utilizes our ring fenced income
and ensures that we can provide our
existing tenants with high quality
safe accommodation that provides tenants
with benefits such as affordable energy
bills
while supporting our wider environmental
aims
this inevitably will involve looking at
invest to save initiatives in order to
free up monies
to enable us to meet the huge challenge
in making our existing housing stock
carbon neutral as demonstrated we need
to maximize our hra receipts to support
the improvements to our existing stock
while supporting our ambitions to build
much needed new affordable homes for our
residents
this is why we are committing 21.5
million
during the next four years to our
capital program for housing maintenance
and renewal
and a further 16.2 million to new build
and acquisitions during the same period
in addition
in recent months we have been successful
in attracting
green homes grant mounting to 618
000 to support external wall insulation
and other fabric first improvements to
tenants homes
this will provide this authority with
adequate provision for pilot schemes for
which learning and practical skills
required
for rollout of more retrofit fabric
first schemes will be available
more funding will be required in future
years as momentum increases
to our co2 emissions reduction targets
by increasing the number of projects
and improved homes i note the green
party amendment talks of this reserve
being used to assist the housing team to
identify the best properties
area and approach for retrofit and
sustainability work
however i am aware the team is already
actively talking to providers that can
provide an energy assessment database of
our housing stock
with intelligence on 85 separate fields
relating to building fabric
energy efficient efficiency renewables
and deprivation
in next year's budget we have initially
allocated our capital program to a total
of nearly 3.5 million pounds
being spent on homes that could be
associated to improving the long-term
energy efficiency and the environment
this members clearly demonstrates our
commitment to our homes
and the environment hence creating an
additional retrofit reserve
is not the solution and a broader review
of how our hra assets and limited
resources
meet all our aspirations will be set out
and put forward
in the hra business plan later this year
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor osborne councilman
mccraw
thank you chair um i came here a few
years ago
quite prepared to speak truth to power
and also to speak truth to those who
would like to be in power and it's a
difficult
area anybody who's spent as much time as
i have
on scrutiny and in audit
and attending cabinet can only have the
utmost respect
for our finance team led by our chief
financial officer
catherine steele they presented a
balanced budget where we didn't think it
was possible and the same applies
to the housing revenue account so i
asked myself the question if that
team had thought it was fiscally
sensible
to borrow a further 2 million because
this eventually will involve borrowing
uh everything does
uh an ill-defined proposal unsupported
by evidence
100 properties at 20 000 per home
this is only for an assessment however
according to the um
actual proposal um so spending two
million just on assessing things which
we should be doing anyway frankly and i
believe from
what councilor osborne has just said we
are doing anyway
seems to me merely um i don't mean to be
rude but it's a little bit posturey
um if we're going to posture let's
posture with some sense behind it
there is a debate to be had on this
assessment
process it's going to cost a lot more
than 2 million pounds of
additional borrowing or any spending um
and i'm
very much aware of the our future
repayment costs
over the next 10 to 15 years because
audits have been looking at that
consistently throughout so i won't be
supporting this motion
and i'd suggest it's probably not a good
one to do
thanks thanks thank you councilman crawl
uh counselor maybe i'm afraid you can't
speak because you've already
spoken once in this debate
was there anyone else who wanted to
speak in this debate so in that case
i'll go to
councillor jameson who is the proposer
of this amendment
uh council jameson
oh yes council lindsay you reserved your
forgot please please proceed
thank you um yeah so
um yes again um
interesting the um
tone of some of the comments
particularly by
council macro i find quite offensive
actually um
the amount of work that we put into this
um
and the assumption that there's no
research um
i'd be interested to know what you know
people like council mccraw
did push for um
a carbon zero homes or better insulated
homes
since we've passed the we passed the um
climate change uh motion
declaration of a climate emergency
get to carbon zero in back in july
2019 so that's more than a year that's
passed and as far as housing is
concerned it seems to have been
wasted now appreciated are some things
that the team are struggling
desperately to try and do an audit of
how many
of what houses we have and what our own
housing stock
of how much energy they're leaking
because we actually don't know
we don't have the epc ratings on half
our council houses so far
we desperately need to accelerate that
process and we need to give the money
to our officers to enable them to do
that with of course we need a reserve
to do that we need to put aside the
money so that we could assure that that
gets done
our officers need it and um
you know this is the to say oh it's
going to cost a lot of money therefore
there's no need to have a reserve
simply doesn't make sense to me if it's
going to cost a lot of money
we need to do it so we need to start
planning for where we get the money
um and at this rate we're still waiting
for a business plan
so so effectively nothing that makes
sense is going into
this year's budget nothing that we know
strategically
will be the best way to reduce carbon as
as um as lee has pointed out councillor
jameson has pointed out
we don't know that we've got the right
strategy at the moment
because we're going on epc ratings
epc ratings aren't probably not the best
way to tell
um whether a house needs insulating more
or not
um so we we need to make sure we've got
the right strategy
we need to do it quickly and and we
appear not to have done that
in the 19 18 months whatever it is
since we passed the climate emergency so
again i'd ask
people as people members
in this virtual chamber are going to
vote against this are you absolutely
sure that
that the housing department is doing
everything it can is prioritizing
retrofitting its council stock and
getting to zero carbon
because if not you should support this
motion thank you
thank you councillor lindsay um so
now um i'll return to council jameson
uh the proposal of this amendment is
there anything you'd like to add
uh thanks cheer uh no nothing more to ed
experiment thanks
thank you councilman jameson council
award is there anything you'd like to
add
no i'm uh i think everything's been said
uh on this
this evening thanks chair okay in that
case we'll move to the vote
um on the amendment i will now ask the
corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the recorded vote
on the amendment housing and climate
change
which is on page 105 in mod gov
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking the plus sign
in the top right hand of the agenda
screen and selecting attendance and
voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote thank you
chair just to say that councillor holt
has left the meeting so the voting is 22
against the amendment and nine for the
amendment
thank you thank you so
the amendment is lost in which case
we'll now return to the original motion
for questions and debates so we'll start
with
questions uh we'll move to questions on
the substantive motion
councils may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question
councillor hinton have you got a
question
thank you madam chairman yes uh
concerning garages i noticed that we've
actually proposing in this
budget that there is no increase in
garage charges
do we know one how many
of our garages are actually used to put
a car into
and what sort of impact increasing
garage charges might have because we're
putting up the cost of accommodation
but we're not putting up the cost of
putting somebody's uh
quite often junk in a in a container
outside
thank you councillor osborne for this
it is madam chairman thank you uh thank
you for the question councillor hinton
um yeah there is a pro there is an
ongoing project to look at um all the
garage sites to see if there's any
possibility
for development and building houses on
them
it's a little bit difficult because
obviously some of them are mixed use and
you're absolutely right
there are very few garages that are
actually used for storing
one's car if we were to increase the
rent the take-up of garages
is is very very small so it would be
pointless to increase the rent on the
garages
because then you'd even reduce the
take-up even less
but there is as i say there is a project
going on for looking at garages to see
how we can maximize the use of the
existing garages that we've got
or not take up the potential for the
site
in repla to replace the garages that are
there
thank you councillor osborne councillor
dawson have you got a question
well actually no i was just going to
respond to councillor hinton actually do
i have to ask a question
yes now you can do that later
the time for questions thank you
you can come back in the debate
councillor dawson for with that
are there any more questions at this
stage
well if there are no more questions um
in that case councillor dawson do
you you can open up the debate
well just coming back to council hinton
to say that actually one of the
unfortunate
things is i mean certainly in hadley we
have you know there's a huge waiting
this my understanding is
to took many years to get a garage but
unfortunately they're all made
because they're so old they're made for
smaller cars
and so um jan's probably quite right we
can't put the prices up because you know
most people
are using them for storage and i've
always suggested
really we should be compulsory
purchasing these garages
years ago and developing them but
apparently we can't find the owners but
i mean that
is something i think they should be
developed
thank you councillor dawson you've
actually um thank you
awesome you've actually shared
that's it thank you
lovely thank you um so
did did anyone want to respond to
councillor dawson's
um comments there
fine no but councillor dawson is on my
screen chair
councillor mayberry did you want to join
the debate
yes thank you i think camps council
dawson has
a very very valid comments there um
i'm absolutely amazed that um the
council
does not see fit to raise the prices
substantially on garages because
then perhaps they may be given up and
then
in that respect the areas would become
available for redevelopment it is true
the bigger cars do not fit in the
garages that were possibly built
decades ago and it is also true that
they're probably full
of um treasured belongings
um and i can attest to that i think i
still have some of my
children's belongings that is stored
um around about my property um but then
that's probably my fault because i
haven't asked them to take that to take
it all away
so i would suggest that the council
should be minded to increase
the the fees on garages substantially
because then obviously they would become
available
thank you thank you councillor mabry
councillor osborne did you want to
respond i do thank you madam chairman
um yeah i i think it would be unfair
to um for those tenants that do actually
use their garage to house their car or
just generally
for storage bearing in mind a lot of our
houses perhaps don't have sufficient
storage
in them i don't think they'd be very
happy if they knew we were increasing
the rent considerably on their garage
to accommodate our need to get people to
give up their garages i don't think that
would be a very good idea
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor owen
thank you i'll get on to this debate as
well i don't know if we should be doing
these for houses um
especially where i'm counsellor you need
a lot more car parking spaces
so if they're going to get rid of the
garages they need to
um make the spaces for the cars
what we've already got so especially at
my
my area so i don't know about building
houses i think we should be doing
more spaces making the garages better
thank you councillor beer
thank you madam chairman that was very
quick um i wasn't going to comment but
uh
once you got onto car partner and gary
your favorite subject
well what
for the garages would actually achieve
uh
anything but i i am in favour of us
looking at to see
how we can perhaps
accommodate those people that have
bought their garages in a block
where some of them are still owned by
the local authority and some are
privately owned
and to see whether we could demolish the
whole block
with their consent rebuild them if they
still want a garage
a larger garage and the spaces that we
achieve from the knock down council
garages that are not wanted
that we make them more parking spaces
for people to park their cars
on the estates with um ev electric
charging points um i don't know whether
the
cabinet member can comment on that
because i think this is a way forward
uh costly yes but if we started um
sooner rather than later we could
eventually accommodate this over a
period of time because we do need to do
something
about the verges about the parking
spaces
around our uh council estates
um i mean we have enough problems on the
private estates but we can
at least start to try and solve some of
them on the
um council estates thank you
councillor osborne would you like to
respond on this yeah thank you madam
chairman yeah as i stated before there
is an ongoing project that is looking at
gerrard's sites in its entirety
um i think yep councillor beer is
absolutely right we do have a real
parking problem um in our town centers
and in our rural areas as well come to
that
which does need to be looked at and that
part of that will be looked at
as the um evolving parking strategy that
will be looking at those issues as well
so we'll be looking to see how that can
be addressed councillor beer
good good thank you thank you
councilman mabry i'm afraid you've
already spoken once in this debate and
you're only allowed your one go
is there anyone else who'd like to take
part in this debate
so if um if no one else has anything
else they'd like to add
council award is there anything else you
would like to add
um not really uh just to say that um
it's
a good uh housing revenue account budget
and uh
i do commend it to to council um and i
fully endorse what
council beer has said about uh reducing
the number of garages
to those who just want them and then
freeing up the space for open parking
because
um he's quite right in in many of our
places we do
need to increase the parking provision
for residents on
on our where we own the houses
so um uh thank you for that chair and uh
that's all i have to say
thank you council ward so we'll move to
the vote in a moment i'll just read out
the recommendations
so the recommendations are 3.1
that the hra budget proposals for 2021
to 22
and four-year outlook set out in the
report be approved
3.2 that the cpi and plus one
increase of 1.5 percent in council house
rents
equivalent to an average rent increase
of one pound 35 a week
be implemented 3.3
that garage rents are kept at the same
level as 2021
20 20 20 21
3.4 that sheltered housing service
charges be increased by 69 pence
per week to ensure recovery of the
actual cost of service
3.5 that sheltered housing utility
charges
are kept at the same level as 2020
21 3.6
that the budgeted surplus of 127
000 be transferred to the strategic
priorities reserve
in 2021-22 3.7
that in principle right to buy receipts
should be retained
to enable continued development and
acquisition
of new council dwellings
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic service
to conduct the recorded vote
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting in
the voting tab the vote for this agenda
item will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote and you will need to tab down
on this vote thank you
chair the voting is 24 for the
recommendations
and seven against thank you
so that vote is carried
thank you so we'll now move on to item
10
recommendations and reports from cabinet
or committees
10a bc 2026
joint capital investment and treasury
management strategies
2021-22 i would like to invite
councillor horan to introduce paper bc
2026
and move the recommendations in the
report
council haran yes thank you madam
chairman this is the most
exciting paper tonight bc 2026
i'll try and keep my intro um down a
little bearing
with respect of the time this report is
the capital investment and treasury
management strategies for 2021
there have been no significant changes
in format this year
and it's been updated to reflect the
latest capital expenditure
investment and borrowing and the latest
treasury management
investment and borrowing positions of
the council
under the sip for treasury management
code of practice
and the prudential code both published
in 2017
and mhc lg investment guidance published
in
2018 we are required to determine
separate
capital investment and strategy
statements and prudential indicators
annually
before the start of each financial year
i'll just run through dependencies the
capital strategy
that's appenders a this summarize the
capital expenditure and financial
requirements of the full
capital program for both the general
fund and housing revenue account
the details details of which are in the
budget report
it shows that capital expenditure plan
for 2021
including carryforwards is 41.4 million
of which 16.4 million will be funded
by borrowing appendices b the investment
strategy this details those expenditure
items in the capital program that
specifically relate to assets bought
and or owned by the councils purely or
partially
to generate a return this includes
schemes which have the
purpose of regeneration or development
of the local area
as well as generating a return in the
context of this strategy
investments mean those non-treasury
management activities
appendix c treasury management strategy
2021
this sets out the council's borrowing
requirement and borrowing and treasury
management investment strategies
this also includes the list of approved
investment counterparties
and their limits there has been no
significant change to limit
since last year appendix d
that's the treasury management
indicators which we use to measure and
manage the council's exposure
to treasury management risks appendix e
economic update and interest rate
forecast
the combined effect of brexit and the
after effects of the pandemic
will dampen growth relative to peers
maintain spare capacity and limit limit
domestically generated inflation
the bank of england are therefore
expected to maintain
loose monetary conditions for the
foreseeable future
appendix f chairman covers the current
investments and debt
portfolio and it shows the position that
30th of november last year
borrowing at the moment totals 107
million
of which 95 and a half million is public
works loan board
and 11.5 is short-term borrowing
on the investment side baby has 15.6
invested this includes ccla
ubs schroeder's investec and the funding
circle
we have continued the policy of
withdrawing funds from the funding
circle as loans drop out
and we have not invested any more new
money
appendix g treasury management policy
statement
underpins the strategy and sets out the
council's regard to the monitoring of
risk
and performance and the primary
objectives remain
security of capital then liquid
liquidity
followed by return and there has been no
richer
no change from last year
appendix h is the minimum revenue
provision statement
appendix i the institutions meeting
higher credit rating criteria
and ends with a glossary of terms which
i'm fast trying to get
used to as um quickly as ever i can
i'm happy to propose paper bc
2026 and look for a seconder
i would like to thank the whole team who
are absolutely brilliant
um i think catherine steele is here to
answer any questions and we've been
joined recently by
rebecca hewitt who i think is also on
hand
she's um a recently joined member only a
few months ago but um
valuable asset and a very sharp cookie
so i'm sure she will
answer questions as well thank you
everybody i'm sorry it's so late
but um we will answer questions between
us
um i am sure thank you thank you
councillor haran could i have a seconder
please
that counselor mclaren would you like to
be the seconder
thank you thank you madam chairman i'm
very happy to second
uh this paper thank you and just want to
add my thanks to the team they've done a
tremendous job
thank you thank you so we'll now move to
questions counselors may ask as many
questions as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question would anyone like
to open the questions
they do not seem to be any questions
so in that case we'll move straight on
to debate
um councils will only be allowed to
speak once or three minutes and this
will be timed
councillor lindsay would you like to
open the debate
sorry i'm a bit late again i just had a
one question
genuine question yes please ask your
question
it was um but we discussed this paper or
um at the audit committee
and um i'm trying to recall now
but we we we proposed a sort of
amendment to the recommendations
i think that was the recommendation of
the cabinet wasn't it not
so i shouldn't look for them in this in
this paper
is that right counselor uh are you
talking
um council lindsay about moving more
towards the green um
agenda and looking at alternatives to
fossil fuels
yes in the um in the in the treasury
investments yeah uh that will that will
be dealt with at the next meeting um
i think you've already been um reassured
of that a lot of the investments we just
can't change we can't um
get out of easily and i'm sure catherine
would back me up on that but
it is work ongoing and i am largely with
you we do need to move and it will
happen but
um it's all a bit time limited
especially with investments
uh okay thank you thank you
does anyone else have anything that
they'd like to add fine
um so counselor horan is there anything
else you would like to add before we go
to the
vote no thank you madam chairman i think
that's it
it's uh a very worthwhile paper that's
the very sort of basis of what we do
and um put together by a very good and
secure team
thank you council haran so in that case
we'll move to the vote
um i won't read out all the
recommendations you have them in front
of you
so i would like to invite the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair
councillors again can you please open
the vote in the modern.gov app
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting the
voting tab for the agenda item will show
in blue and please click on the blue
line to open the vote
again councillors you will need to tab
down thank you
chair the voting is 26 4 3 against and
one abstention
thank you thank you
so that vote is carried thank you
item 11 councillor appointments
are there any changes to policings
so i don't think there are any changes
to placings
so in that case if there's nothing
no there's no further business this
evening it's been a long evening but
thank you very much for your attendance
and i look forward to seeing you all
again
uh the next meeting is tuesday the 23rd
of march and it's at 5
30 so i look forward to seeing you all
then
and have a good rest of the evening not
much of it left
you